- I'm ambidextrous.
When I'm jacking off.
- I need to use both
hands for my massive cock
(laughing).
- We're recording this
you guys, this is gonna...
- You guys need more practice.
(laughing)
- Switch hands.
(all laughing)
- Have you tried to jack
off with the other hand,
and it's like...
- It's like workout,
- No nothing happens.
- I drilled.
(all laughing)
- I throw the hands to one hand.
- This is not the conversation
I wanted to discuss.
- Leave, leave Trash
Taste now while you can.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to this episode of Trash Taste,
I'm the boy...
Why you laughing I haven't
said anything funny?
- You sound so robotic.
- You would, I don't know,
It was like such low energy
and I was just expecting
you to project your voice
and you're like, welcome..
- Yeah like your cadence
is really uplifting,
but just the volume you said it out
was just so unenthusiastic.
- Welcome to Trash Tastes podcast!
- There we go,
there we go.
- I'm the monkey brain
and today I'm in my mirror, when
(screaming)
I'm today with Joey and Conner of course.
how are you guys doing this?
- I mean much better now.
I'm awake after that scream.
- I needed that scream to wake
me up, to get in the zone.
- It works man, it works.
I don't know if my neighbors,
pretty wakes them up as well actually,
pretty hurts them actually.
- They don't need an alarm clock anymore
they just hear..
(yelling)
(Garnt yelling)
- You got this Conner, you've got this.
- It's time to wake up.
(laughing)
- Conner snoozed that alarm.
- Oh my good God, oh my God!
So have you guys been this week?
- Good.
(all laughing)
- Yeah. Pretty good.
(laughing)
- We fucking see each other all the time.
Why are you asking me?
What am I up to?
- No I mean, because
we all the three of us
went on trips this week.
- Oh yeah.
- You wanna talk about that?
- Yes, sure.
We went to rafting.
It was not white water rafting.
It was like playing a cut scene.
(laughing)
That's basically what
our rafting was like.
(laughing)
It was like we had to paddle,
the maximum was three times
- Right.
- And then the rest was just floating
downstream in the river.
- It did feel like a shitty
house of the dead cut scene.
- Right.
- Asks secrets where
you press the gun once,
- Yeah.
- And you just can't skip it.
- We have like the quick turn of events
where you had to press X three times
(laughing)
And then
that was like the interaction
with the cut scene.
(laughing)
- One point they were like, yeah,
you can jump in the river,
and then they were like, yes
so you always put your foot in me and God
just fucking jumped in head first?
But then I didn't realize
it was like this deep.
(laughing)
So I immediately was
like, yes, it's my time.
And I just jumped in
and fucking slam my helmet into the floor.
(laughing)
- At least you were wearing a helmet.
- Yeah, we'll see.
- I'm pretty sure what
they were gonna warn us
that it was too shallow,
but the moment they said you can jump in,
before they could explain anything else,
me and Connor just like jumped head first-
- Monkey brain just like yeeeh!
- 'Cause it was so hot and we
were just dying to jump in.
- I really, really wanted
to jump in the water
the whole time.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- But Joey went on vacation
with his other friends.
Can you believe Joey's
friends outside of us too?
- What the fuck?
- No.
- The fuck Joey?
- They're acquaintances
(laughing)
- Now, I went up to Hokkaido,
to Hakodate.
- Fuck you.
(laughing)
- So careless
- Without the boys I know,
was absolute blasphemy,
but it was so fucking nice because
actually, speaking of which I've got
like a bunch of like
presents for the boys.
- Okay. This is a surprise.
- While Joey is getting his presents out,
we have a new camera angle
and that's because we need-
- Hello?
- The space behind it,
and if you hate it, that's tough shit,
you're gonna have to get used to it.
- This podcast studio is
actually relatively small.
I remember the first thing Chris said
when he came into the podcast was like,
it looks a lot bigger.
- It was like a casing room.
- But all our camera used
to be right in the back,
and we basically couldn't use the center
of the room with half of it.
- There's just like a lot of empty space
that we couldn't use if
we use the old camera.
- Hey, if you'd like to
see the behind the scenes
then follow us on Twitter.
But, okay here.
- Thank you very much.
- So this is one of the gifts...
- I did not get you a gift,
this is kind of awkward.
(Conner laughing)
- I feel bad now.
- This two trips you've been
and all you brought me a gift
and I have been on one and...
(laughing)
- The first time I got you guys gifts,
the fucking snacks expired
before you even ate it.
- You never told me I
should eat them quickly.
- Okay, eat these quickly then.
- We'll just eat these now.
- I guess, so this is a type of a cookie.
- You know what?
- Yeah just, just rip it open.
- I'm monkey brain, what am I doing?
- I'm gonna be civilized.
- So this is the type of..
(laughing)
You're like a five-year-old.
Yeah. So this is the type of cookie
that you can only get in..
Hokkaido it's kind of
known for it's called,
Shiroi Koibito which means white lover.
(laughing)
- I'm civilized.
- It's so well wrapped.
I just needed to bust that shit open.
- Yeah. So this is a type of cookie
that you can only get in Hokkaido.
It's called Shiroi Koibito
- Thank you very much Joey.
- Really, really nice.
It's white chocolate, like milk cookies.
'Cause you know, Hokkaido
is known for its milk.
- Hokkaido is known for a lot of things.
- Dude, Hoikkaido is-
- Milk, I've heard-
- But Hokkaido has like perfected food.
That's the only way to describe it.
Everything I had in Hokkaido
tasted so much fucking better-
- It's like a cream pie..
- Yeah, kind of.
- Don't say that.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- No, it's every..
- Oh, wow!
- Is it melted?
- No no no, it's all good.
- Is it good?
- Hoo, hoo
- Where did you get that?
- Yeah. Which like...
When I heard you say like
Hokkaido has amazing food
I'm thinking man, anywhere
in Japan already has
amazing food.
I can't imagine somewhere
leveling up that-
- Fuji? If it's just like the seafood,
even just for the seafood, right?
Because where I was in Hakodate
its a coastal town-
- [Conner] That's really good.
- So they catch all of the seafood there
like fresh at the fucking port and it's...
Oh my God.
They have a fish market there
that we went to in the morning
and all of the seafood
that they sold there,
they caught that morning.
So it's the freshest seafood
you can ever get, legit,
think of the best seafood you had,
and imagine that is just trash.
(all laughing)
because that's what-
- It's garbage,
it's useless.
- It's garbage
compared to what you can have in Hakodate.
So I got you another
thing as well because..
- Oh, wow! That's kind of funny.
- So there's this...
- You got a wishlist on Amazon
or something I can like.
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
- I wanted to get you...
I wanted to get this for you guys
because I feel it's very indicative
of a kind of a vibe that we go for.
- All right, okay.
- Okay.
- It's clown juice
(all laughing)
- What?
- Here's some clown juice for the boys.
- Hamburger-
- Hamburger Pierrot,
Lucky Pierrot.
- Yeah. So there's this hamburger joint.
That's specific only to Hakodate,
not even Hokkaido
and it's called Lucky Pierrot,
and they have their own
branded energy drinks.
- Right?
- Because, do you guys
know what, like guarana is?
Like the fruit that they use
in Red Bull and stuff like that?
- Oh yes.
- Yeah.
- They grow Guarana in Hokkaido,
and so, I guess they just took that
and it's literally just clown juice.
(all laughing)
- You literally just send
us an IRL clowney motive.
- Yeah. I was like, he's a clown cod,
drink up boys.
(Garnt laughing)
- Anytime one of us has a shit take,
we gotta take a drink.
- Yes, just take a sip of the clown juice.
How is it though?
- Tastes like an energy drink.
- Honestly, for me it kinda tastes like,
some weird as it's to say,
it's like a healthier Red Bull.
- It's like a Red Bull
with a stronger aftertaste.
- I don't know, it's definitely got that-
- I think that's definitely
the Guarana you are tasting.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I can't decide if it
tastes cheap or expensive.
- I'll tell you,
(Conner laughing)
this was 150 yen.
So I'll tell you..
- I'll tell you what,
It actually tastes like a tire Red Bull.
- Oh really?
- And to explain what
tire Red Bulls are like,
so, Red Bull actually
originates from Thailand,
- Oh Really?
- And yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- So Red Bull actually
originated from Thailand,
but the version they have in
Thailand is not carbonated.
It's like a thick syrup.
And whenever like...
The only people who really
drink Red Bull in Thailand,
it's truck drivers, it's
like you need to stay up
because you drink one and
last like drinking five...
The equivalent of five Red
Bulls you get anywhere else.
- Jesus Christ-
- One American breakfast.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, but I think this
has probably the same amount
of caffeine as like a regular Red Bull,
but I think..
- We're gonna be loaded on this podcast.
- But yeah.
But they also have the
non-carbonated stuff as well.
So they have like Guarana juice
which is just beer
basically, it's as you said,
it's like a non-carbonated
Red Bull essentially.
And I had that,
and actually it tastes
really fucking good.
And I think it works better
than a coffee, in my opinion.
Even though it has just as
much caffeine as a coffee.
So suffice it to say that
for the rest of this episode,
we'll all just fucking
had a coffee as well.
- You gonna see
when this energy drink hits.
- Yeah.
- Cause we're gonna be like-
- You'll be able to see
the heart palpitations
through the screen.
- I need like a beer
to like downer.
(all laughing)
- We definitely gonna kill
ourselves this episode.
But yeah, I just wanted to
get you guys some gifts.
- Thank you very much.
- Now I feel super bad
that we didn't give anything.
(Joey laughing)
- No it's okay.
- Although we didn't really
get any souvenirs either
for ourselves.
- That's all right.
But hopefully, it will actually be able
to take like a proper
boys' trip up to support
'cause I know you guys have been saying
how much you wanna go
up to the North, right?
- Yeah. I really do. I really, really do.
- I really wanna go in the winter,
'cause it seems like
really a lot of things
happening in the winter.
- Oh yeah.
- I wanna hit up the onsen in the winter.
- That's gonna be so nice.
- Yeah.
- Just wanna get naked.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I just wanna get naked with the boys.
- We haven't talked about onsens
on this podcast publicly, have we?
- I've seen your guy's dicks so much now
that I don't even question it,
going to the onsen with you.
It's like it used...
I don't know...
- Are you mad?
- The first time we used to go...
First time went to the onsen together
I was like, well, we got
to like see each other's
- Penises?
- Penises. Yeah.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Do you know how Joey
cares? It's kind a loot.
(all laughing)
But now it's just like whatever,
we're getting naked with the boys.
- Another day with the boys.
But I feel like a lot of people are afraid
to go to onsens for the first time.
Because of that barrier,
where you just have to be naked
in front of the boys-
- I mean, in a lot of countries
it's not very normal, is it?
- Some people have been like, yeah,
you wanna come to the onsen with me?
And immediately it's no,
I don't wanna do that. I'm like why?
And they're like, oh, cause
I don't wanna get naked.
And I'm like, it's just that...
It wasn't even like a
decision, it was in the head.
It was like, of course it's
no, I'm not getting naked.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But it's like, but
everyone around you is naked.
- So you're not gonna be
the only one that's naked.
- Most European countries,
it's like we're naked.
- Yeah.
But that's surprising though, isn't it?
Is that like I've tried
to convince so many
of my European friends to go on an onsen
because in my head, it's just like,
oh bathing together is like a
very normal thing in Europe,
in a lot of European countries.
So I'm like, Oh, well, if
it's normal in their country
and their culture, then must be easy.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Yeah
- So many times I'm like, hey,
you wanna go to the onsen?
They're just like, no.
- I think, I don't know.
Maybe our generation, it's less of a thing
than it was like 20 years ago?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it could be the older generation.
'Cause I remember trying
to convince my cousin
to go to the onsen when he visited Japan,
and it was just like
breaking down layers, right?
So first I'm just like, yeah, it's kinda
like how can these...
'Cause he is the biggest
norm you can imagine,
so how do I explain the cultural
significance of an onsen
and a hot spring to someone
who has never watched an anime?
- Right.
- This is the same cousin
that watched the live action
a title in time?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Okay, Okay.
- That's right.
And he's like seven,
eight years older than me,
So he's from the older generation as well.
So, had to be like, okay, so
it's kinda like a hot tub,
but it's like a public hot tub
- [Conner] Yeah.
- And then he was like,
oh yeah, that sounds fun,
you know, so he was like, Oh yeah-
- That's it?
- Yeah, so real,
so you wear a bathing suit
and everything, right?
And I was like,
(Joey laughing)
okay, so, here's the thing,
you just...
Everyone's naked, and you know,
it's just a really relaxing experience,
(Joey laughing)
and it's a really cool experience.
And I mean, his voice tone
just completely changed,
he was just, oh yeah, it's true.
I won't know about that one chief.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I love how you had to go
in such a roundabout way.
It wasn't just like, yeah, we get naked.
It was like, well, I mean...
- We've got bathing suits.
We just take them off.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Just take them off.
- You can wear bathing
suits until you enter.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause what was the
first onsen experience
for you guys like?
'Cause I remember-
- I was with you guys.
- Yeah.
- I think it was when we all went with...
I think it was us three and Allen.
- Yeah, that's first time.
- In the old onsen,
in old diver.
- Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
Which is like a massive,
it's like a super sento,
super onsen as it's called, but-
- And I remember the fact of knowing that
we're gonna get naked
in front of each other,
that was just like...
I think I had just built
it up in my mind so much
'cause I'm just like,
it's about to happen,
it's about to happen.
- I remember that day, like
we all stepped into the onsen
and Allen was like all
right lads, whip them out.
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
Let's just get it out of the way.
Let's just all-
- Put them on the table,
get the mojos out.
- Gather around in a circle,
and we'll just look it up,
ditch our sticks,
(Garnt laughing)
and then just be over it.
And we're like, all
right, three, two, one,
we'll look at the dicks
like okay, we good?
No, one's popping a fart?
All right we good.
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah. And then it just
literally took five minutes
and then I was completely comfortable.
And then it was an amazing experience.
Then i feel like people who are so afraid
to go off that barrier, are missing
such a good experience
of going to an onsen.
- It's an experience you
can't really get anywhere else
I feel, like even I've
been to kind of, you know,
public bathing places in Europe as well.
But this just, I don't know.
It's just, I don't wanna
say it hits different, but..
(Darnt laughing)
You know, there's something
that's not quite right-
- There's the vibe, is just different.
- Yeah.
- It's definitely like vibe check.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Hey y'all onsen check.
- Onsen check, yeah bro.
- I don't think we have public
bathing places in Europe.
Do we? But we have like
the saunas, which are...
- But it's kind of similar, right?
- There's a similar.
- I guess, Yeah. You don't
really bathe together,
you just get into the sort of naked
and some people are like,
they'll cover themselves.
- I don't know, because for me,
it's not just the onsen experience.
It's everything around
is the onsen experience.
Like getting out of the
onsen when you're like...
Especially in the winter,
sitting out in in a public onsen
when it's really cold
or sometimes raining,
and it's I thought when it's snowing,
it's amazing as well.
- It's so good.
- Yeah. That's like...
I put it's proper anime where
there's mist in everything.
I want to experience that one day.
But after coming out and
having that drink of cold milk,
- Yeah.
- That's like the most refreshing-
- Hand on the hip.
- Hand on the hip here.
So what you do, you have to
put your hand on the hip,
drink the milk and wine and
it's the most refreshing
glass of milk-
- You don't have to.
- But it's like vibra,
you've got to do it.
And then having an
izakaya beer afterwards,
it's just fucking incredible.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It makes you...
When you're in an onsen,
for some reason it makes
you wanna just be a CEO
and talk business.
(Joey laughing)
Like I don't even have
business to talk about
but I'll be like, gentlemen let's discuss,
the topic at hand, and
they're like animated issues.
(all laughing)
It just makes you wanna
talk about important things
to get in a bath with three other people.
- It's exactly the same kind of vibe,
but a different kind of vibe.
So we went to the...
The other day, went to a cigar bar,
I don't know what it is
about having a fat cigar
on your hand, you just
wanna talk business, and-
(Joey laughing)
- You take a puff, you're like,
we have a problem.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
We need to eliminate someone.
- We're right in the groove.
(all laughing)
We got exterminated.
- I remember we went for
cigars with PewDiePie, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And he was like, damn,
your voice got even deeper with the cigar.
(Joey and Darnt laughing)
I was like, I was made for this field.
(all laughing)
- First time I had that cigar,
I was like, Oh my God, I
could finally understand why
mafia bosses is still so powerful
with a cigar in their hand.
because it's like-
- It's got an energy to it.
- Yeah.
- There is, yeah.
- I don't...
I never smoke at all. But for
some reason the idea of cigars
like that sounds good, I like that.
- Well, because unlike a cigarette, right?
You don't inhale the cigar smoke, right?
So, I mean, don't get me
wrong, it's still bad for you.
- It's still terrible.
- It's still terrible for you.
- And you come out of
the bar smelling like
you've just like puffing exhaust pipe.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
That's kind of the smell
of that
- Yeah.
But man, you feel so powerful
just with that aura of cigar around you,
like yes, I just came out
of the cigar bar wide open.
(Garnt laughing)
- Mind your business
what are you looking at?
- Yeah, you do have a different
aura around you, don't you?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You just feel powerful.
- It's like when you
order a drink at a bar,
it's like you're the virgin.
When you order a drink at the cigar bar,
it's like, they used to chat,
but then you're like name a
cocktail, any cocktail? A vodka.
- What do you always get
again is Espresso martini.
- Espresso martini, if you haven't had it,
it's an amazing drink. It's just coffee.
Just with a vodka.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- It's amazing, it just
tastes right.
- It's just
coffee with attitude really.
- I love my-
- Coffee with attitude?
(all laughing)
What a terrible way to describe it.
- It's a coffee with attitude.
- That's like-
- It is.
- Describing anything with attitude-
- Why are you booing me, am right.
(all laughing)
- Because it's such like...
I don't know, that sounds like it.
How a Disney character is
introduced in a short, oh yeah...
He's the bully with attitude.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- After we go to the
bar, I'll take a coffee
with attitude please, hold the attitude.
- Well, yeah.
- I hate it here.
(all laughing)
I hate it here.
- It's like shit.
Today when you got a frappuccino
and you're like, no, I didn't
just get a frappuccino,
I got an espresso frappuccino.
(Conner and Joey laughing)
- I was like, Oh my God,
you couldn't love Santa anymore white?
- It's like 35 Celsius.
I want an ice cream and a drink in one,
but I also want a coffee.
So yeah, I don't...
I normally think frappuccinos are awful,
but I bent my own morals.
- So you best still got a
frappuccino with attitude, right?
(Joey laughing)
- I hate it here, I hate it here so much.
(all laughing)
- Just add anything with attitude
and I'll just make it sound
bad and much more horrible.
- All the fucking comments
now are gonna be like,
damn, that was something with attitude.
(all laughing)
Oh my God.
- I love that, I love that to be a meme.
That's gonna be a meme now.
- Now I'm gonna describe everything
with something with attitude now.
- Yeah it's something with attitude now.
- But-
- You're welcome.
- Speaking of cigar bars,
I think the topic for today
that we wanted to discuss was
nightlife in Tokyo, right?
- Yeah.
- Or in Japan in general.
- Just take japan in general.
- True, true.
I mean, I wouldn't know
I haven't been at night
outside of Japan for a while.
(all laughing)
- For a while, yeah.
- I miss her.
(all laughing)
I miss the English.
- 'Cause I mean, what is a
typical nightlife for say,
UK or Thailand or Australia?
'Cause I don't know what the
nightlife is in Thailand.
- I mean the nightlife in
Thailand is, I mean it's-
- Okay, let me ask the
question, does it exist?
- Yeah, of course.
- That's all Thailand is.
- It definitely exists
and there's different
kinds of vibes you can go for,
you can go for a disgusting cheap like
my life in Bangkok or you can go
for some more extravagant
bars and everything.
It's very varied but I don't know
if I would say that there
a significant culture
that pertains all of Thailand,
but I feel like with Japan,
there's definitely like
the izakaya culture,
- Yeah.
- Which I fucking love.
You talk about nightlife in Thailand,
whenever I'm in Thailand,
I just go to izakaya.
(all laughing)
'Cause I like the vibe that much, yeah.
- Yeah that's the thing right,
I feel an izakaya is just, I mean,
should we explain what an izakaya is
just in case people don't know?
- Sure.
- For those who are uncultured,
it's basically a Japanese pub.
- Basically, but like...
- It's like...
- It's a restaurant and a pub combined.
- It's 75% pub and 25% restaurant.
- Yeah.
- That's what I would say.
But like in a pub in the UK,
I thought-
- But it's not depressing.
- Yeah, yeah. It's depressing,
and also for some reason,
I always feel pressured
to live in the UK or just
drink, not sit down and eat.
But I have this pressure
that's like drink,
you're not here to eat,
'cause when you go out with
your friends to the pub,
I'm always that asshole whose like,
I'm getting a meal, you
wanna ask for a meal?
- Because it's just really inconvenient,
'cause you're there with
a table for the pints-
- Tiny table molded.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then there's this guy he just orders
a three-course meal,
and you're like where
are we meant to fit this?
- I don't give a shit
about us to hold out this-
- I would like slowly notch
the 12 beers out of the way
to make room for my extravagant
curry from Wetherspoons.
(all laughing)
Under the tables like
down here just like this,
you're like this.
- Its like bombing out.
- Do you like pubs?
- In the UK?
- Yeah.
- I loved them in London.
I thought London had great pubs.
- I don't know, I really don't like pubs.
Pubs are the one thing
about the UK that I...
Anytime I go out the UK, I'm like, yes,
this is a much better drinking
establishment than a pub,
'cause it's just...
I don't know what it is
about pubs in the UK,
I just find it so fucking depressing,
'cause
- Yeah I can see that.
- It depends which ones you go to.
London has ton of bar like
pubs that are really lively
and really great atmosphere.
But there are also equally as bad.
- I mean, you guys took me to one.
It was like a gaming pub, right?
- That's shut down now.
- Oh really?
(Conner and Joey laughing)
- That pub was a mess there.
- I wouldn't even call that a bar,
- I wouldn't even call it a ...
- That was like a gaming bar,
but like the dirtiest gaming bar.
- And what was it called again?
- Meltdown.
- It was a gaming bar with five PCs,
one dirty old, WeYou-
- No it wasn't even a
WeYou, it was just We.
- We, a WeYou, and
there'll be the same people
who'd hog the PCs and there's
no clement or anything,
so it was just awful, it was terrible.
- Yeah, that's quite right.
- You know, you compare a
gaming bar anywhere else
and you're like, dude, they've got games.
- Yeah. They got real games.
- The way I would describe Meltdown is
it's basically like a uni-bar.
- Hmmm.
- But the charges-
- They charge more
than the uni-bar.
- But it was just like a run down bar,
and like every single bar in London
that is even remotely interesting,
I feel is sort of run down, unfortunately.
- Yeah. I can see that.
- 'Cause I don't know the
thing about pubs that I hate is
that for some reason,
they just seem so dark.
I don't know. It's...
- I don't know what pubs you go into man,
there's so many in London and it's so fun.
- Anytime I go to a pub style
bar, like anywhere else,
the first thing I notice is,
man, it's so bright in here.
(Joey laughing)
This is nothing like British pubs.
This is nothing like British pubs, at all.
- Are you going to the pubs
that are down the alley?
- I just go into like the
proper light local pubs,
'cause in the UK, there's
the pubs that anyone goes to
and then there's the pubs that have
the exact same 30 people go to.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And those are the
depressing and dark ones.
- I don't know, 90% of
Wetherspoons I'd say
fit on the backend story.
- That's just...
Yeah okay, most Wetherspoons are...
Wetherspoons is a brand of pubs in the UK.
It's just like this ultra treat brand.
- Yeah, you took me to one.
- I did take you to one,
I think it's I liked it.
- And the reason people go there
is 'cause of the very, very cheap drinks
and cheap food they eat together.
- Or was this five pounds
for a full course meal
or something with a beer?
- You basically like a full course meal
with an alcoholic drink
for seven pounds, like $9,
(Joey laughing)
in London which is...
In London the drinks
alone normally were $8,
which I'm pretty people
in California are like,
Oh, that's cheap, in the UK that's...
bear in mind where I grew up,
a drink that's over three
pounds, which is like $4,
it's like wow, get low to this guy.
- Yeah because if you
go to a pub in Australia
for a pint it's nine bucks.
- Yeah. I mean where...
The Wetherspoons, which is the cheap areas
of where I grew up, it was
like their main selling point
was two pound pints,
and sometimes some of the
special brews were one pound 60.
- Wow.
- So that's
like $2 something for a pint.
- Yeah.
- No wonder that there's...
People are in there from 2:00
PM until 9:00 PM to dead.
- Getting their money's worth.
- Yeah. 'Cause to me,
pubs are just the place
where you pre-drink
before you actually go out
to the establishment you
want to go to, right?
That's how I see it.
Whereas with izakayas,
I can fucking stay there
from the beginning of the
night, to the end of the night.
- Yeah.
- You don't feel pressured to leave
and you don't really have like...
They're normally cordoned off decently
while when you feel like
it's just you and your mates.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Whereas sometimes the
pubs having to see everyone
around you is a little
like, Oh my God, it's busy.
- Yeah that's one thing
I don't like about,
I guess UK style pubs and
there are a few of those
in Japan as well.
There's a place called the Hub
(Garnt laughing)
Which I'm sure you boys are aware of.
It's a...
Don't go there by the way,
because it's like going
into a UK pub, but in Japan.
So why the fuck would you do that?
- But brighter?
- [Conner] Okay. But-
- But it's a little bit brighter.
- I've heard there, if you're a foreigner
and you really wanna pick up some people
who are really into foreigners,
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- They are probably there
because they know that
foreigners go there.
- If you have the yellow
fever but can't be bothered
to go the traditional
route, go to the Hub.
Yeah. But like..
- The Hub at Shibuya, you'll just be fine.
- But every time I go
into a Hub, it's just...
Well, first of all, it's
like 99% foreigners.
- It's also very depressing.
- It's also very depressing because
it's kind of structured like-
- That's what I'm saying, right?
- It's structured like a UK pub where
the seats are kind of sporadic
and then everyone is standing around you,
so you just feel really close to her.
- Yeah. I don't mind
standing and drinking.
Sometimes standing is fun.
- I don't know, it's like I need a table.
It definitely needs to be a table there
where I can leave my drink.
If I'm just standing in a corner,
which sometimes on like a
Friday or Saturday night
in England where some pubs are crowded
and you just have to stand there
in the middle of the floor,
just with your mates,
I'm just like, this is not
the vibe I want to go for.
- My legs hurt, I want to sit down.
- Yeah. The thing I like
about izakaya is that
you're always sitting down,
you have your own sanctioned corner
where you can just sit
and talk to your mates.
And it's just the perfect
kind of catch up vibe
I look for when I just wanna
just chill with my mates
and just chill-
- That's also so cheap,
like you can go to any izakaya here
and the most you'll
pay for a beer is what?
Like 400 yen? Maybe, that's
a pretty expensive one.
- That's an expensive one.
- Yeah. I'm saying like
the max you'll pay.
- Yeah. Normally you pay
between 200 and 300 yen
for a beer, which is like $23 dollars.
- I went to an izakaya that
where it was at 50 yen beers.
- What's the point?
- 50 yen.
- How do we even compete?
'Cause one thing that
doesn't make sense to me,
is that sometimes it's
cheaper to drink in an izakaya
than it is to go to a family
market or konbini and buy-
- A can of beer.
- Buy a can of beer, which is like...
Can you imagine if that
was the case in the UK?
Like if going to Tesco's is more expensive
than going to your local Wetherspoons?
I'm just like, nobody would drink at home.
Everyone would just be
out constantly drinking.
(Joey laughing)
- I think the UK economy would just stop.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I think the country would fail.
- Oh my God.
Yeah. But like...
I think the one thing I
like about izakayas is that,
again, even people who don't drink
can still go to an izakaya
and have a good time.
Because as you know, we've
established it's mostly
drink based, but the
food a lot of the times
is also so freaking good and
cheap, that you could be...
Probably one of as much
fun if you want drinking,
but, you can easily take your friend
who doesn't drink at all,
and they'll probably still
have a decent time, right?
- Yeah, 'cause like the food there,
you can easily order a
lot of snack kind of food,
it's not like you have to order a meal,
you know what I mean?
- So like a giant fucking pub burger?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I will say that I do feel
the food is a coin flip
sometimes at the izakayas,
like you can normally tell
which ones are gonna have bad food,
but sometimes the food is just really bad.
- Are you only saying that
because you got food poisoning?
- No, I did get food poisoning,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I did get food poisoning very
recently from the izakaya,
but then, the more I've
been living in Japan
and the more I've been eating
out at restaurants in Japan,
the more I realized like my God,
this food is so much better
than the izakaya food.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'm like, yeah, it's fine,
and you know, normally just
taking the Carnegie and,
which is like the Japanese
boneless fried chicken.
- I mean yeah, don't get me wrong,
the izakaya food is good
but there's definitely like...
If you want proper food,
- There's somewhere...
- You need to go to a
proper establishment.
- There's sometimes
that I'm in an izakaya,
I'm eating and I'm like,
God, this food is depressing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's like really?
There's one Nero while we're
filming this, that like...
You know the one, it was
the underground place.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they had the driest
chicken I'd ever seen in my life.
You think of like they'd
have let this chicken out
to die in the Sahara desert
before they harvested it.
- Yeah, it was pretty anemic, was it?
- Yeah.
- Everything on it was just kinda like,
all right, I guess you just
didn't love your job today.
- Yeah. The food...
That one is definitely like...
It's not horrible.
- Do you know its gonna be that bad?
When like the menu, everything is 150 yen?
- Oh yeah.
- Well, you get what
you pay for, sometimes-
- Right, right.
- But like comparing
Izakaya food to some of
the pub food that I'm used to,
I don't know, I feel like-
- I think pub food's really
fucking good in the UK.
Am I-
- Really?
- Yeah, maybe I'm too white
to make this point, but-
- I don't know, 'cause if I had a choice,
pub food is where I go if
I have no other choice,
so I can't be bothered to cook for myself.
- I promise right, hand on heart,
If I had to choose between izakaya food
and English pub food, I'd
go with pub food, no joke.
- Well, I'm gonna go with izakaya food.
- Joey's fucking biased.
- No, I'm not.
- He is never gonna admit that.
- Not at all.
- I don't care about your opinion Joey.
- No. Okay shut up for a second.
(all laughing)
- Okay, fine.
- Okay. 'Cause it's the
kind of the same thing
with Australian pub food as well.
- I don't know man, I can't comment.
Yours is a wild card.
- 'Cause Australian
pubs is kind of the same
as the UK pubs right?
Where most people just go to drink
and usually it's very fucking depressing
'cause it's just a bunch
of middle-aged dudes,
who've been sitting there
since 2:00 PM, right?
Just wasting their life away.
But like a lot of pubs in Australia,
they have really fucking good food.
But the problem is that you
only get a set portion of food,
for a stupid amount of money.
- [Conner] Right.
- Right. And so sometimes-
- So it's like a cost thing.
- Yeah. Yes, cheap-
- The only thing is that I smell broke.
Joey's broke.
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
- You will be once you...
After you go to an
Australian pub, you will be.
It's 25 bucks for a fucking pizza.
It's just not worth it, but like...
But the thing is that
with Australian pub food,
a lot of it's good, but
there's just like you know,
even before you go into the pub,
what food is gonna be there?
- [Conner] Yeah, yeah-
- There is just so little variety...
And you know, same thing
could be said with izakayas,
but I feel that-
- It's always the same shit in izakayas.
- I don't know, man, different izakayas
have different things that
they specialize in I feel.
- Yeah but then, but yeah..
- But pubs are always
just like burgers, pizza-
- No, no. The reason
I love izakaya food is
they're designed to go well
with the beer or alcohol
that you're drinking.
- It's just the perfect...
It's the synergy you were
talking about, the pizza synergy.
- I was right about that by away.
(Joey laughing)
- It just synergizes so well together,
whereas with pub food,
it's the same kind of meal.
- It's just like put this in your stomach.
- I think yes, sometimes it
is, but not all the time.
There's been plenty of
izakayas we've been to
where I'm like, this is just weak,
this is mid as you would say Joey.
- I mean I wasn't even gonna say that-
- But even like the mid
izakayas are still better
than some of the best pub food.
I don't know...
I just don't like pubs, I'm sorry England,
I don't like pubs.
- You know what though?
I do really like Irish
pubs for their food.
'Cause I feel that at
least with Irish pubs,
unlike UK pubs, there's a
little more variety in the food,
and there's I feel, at
least from my experience,
I feel less-
- I took you to shitty pubs there.
- But I feel less pressure
to get out of an Irish pub,
than I do in a UK pub
if I'm not just sitting there drinking.
- Hold that-
- Yeah, I like Irish pubs.
- It's normally...
Where were you drinking? In Dublin or?
- Yeah. Dublin and I'd
went to something like
Limerick and stuff like that
but they were all around Ireland.
- Yeah. I mean the norm in
the UK, apart from England
'cause I think a lot of
England is just depressing
outside of the big cities, no offense.
In the small towns, in Wales and stuff,
there's some really fun pubs
'cause it's just like 20-
- I'm not gonna go to wales.
- No, no, you are not.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
There's no reason to go to Wales charity.
I'm sorry Wales.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Wales, it's true,
We have to accept that
fact unless you like-
- I like sheep?
- Do you like nature Joey?
- I like sheep.
- Do you like rundown
castles? Do you like those?
- It's just hit or miss for me.
- All right. You have love what...
(Conner and Joey laughing)
- That's all it is.
- That is not really too much to do.
- I wanna go to that fucking Lake
that has the longest name in the world.
- I know, that's sort
of like that's a town.
- Oh It's a town.
- Yeah. And it's
Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogerychwyrndrobwllllantysiliagogogoch.
is the town named Joey.
How dare you not tell that?
- Honestly you could have
completely made that up.
I'd probably be like, yes.
- Is that true?
- Yes, that's right.
- Correctly.
I actually was gonna make a video
or I went to that place.
I actually filmed it, I filmed it all.
- Was that the town where the news anchor
pronounced imperfectly,
- Yeah.
- And that just went viral?
- Just up the road from
Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogerychwyrndrobwllllantysiliagogogoch,
the temperature you got at 21 Celsius.
- It's like 6 millimeters.
- Yeah. So I went there and
I filmed a video actually,
but I have all this
footage though, and like I-
- So wait, so what's in it?
- It's just me going around this place.
Just checking out.
- No but I mean, what's the town like?
- It's fucking dead.
(all laughing)
it was fucking rotten dead.
- Is it dead because no one
can pronounce the place?
- Maybe I don't...
So it's about...
It was like two hours
drive from where I grew up.
So I asked one of my mates, I was like,
hey, can we go over here and
just film a bunch of shit?
I don't know why I was like, fuck it,
maybe something fun will happen.
Though nothing fun happened obviously.
But there was also a climbing
place that we wanted to go to,
so we'll just go there after
we are done with filming.
- Climb you mean the hill?
- No, no, no, like a climbing gym.
- Ooooh, climbing gym,
I get.
- It's huge,
huge warehouse, pretty cool.
So if you wanna go there,
there's a climbing gym
inside there,
but I went there, and it was just a bunch
of tourists from England,
- All right.
- They were old, very, very
old, like sixties plus,
just hanging around, just checking it out,
there's a gift shop, tiny.
And then there's a bunch of stores,
and I went in there, you know, asking...
'Cause we were in a
really West part of Wales,
and they normally could speak Welsh.
And I was like, Oh, well,
maybe I'll ask around
and see if anyone could speak Welsh.
No one could speak fucking Welsh.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah. I was surprised,
'cause normally in that far West,
I think that County is the
one with the highest rate
of welsh literacy as well.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Right.
- So, yeah, nothing there.
- Nothing there?
- So if you've ever wondered
what's there, nothing.
- [Joey] Nothing.
- Just a really comically
large train sign.
- Yeah.
- It's actually like-
- How do they fit in?
Is it on size two font?
- No no on, you know the normal...
So normally in the UK,
each one has like a standard size of font.
It's quite big.
They literally just add it on.
They're like they drill it on by hand.
- There is a really funny image
of a guy standing next to
it and it's 10 meters long.
- It's really, really...
I'll have some footage
up from the video that
Meilyne Tran can just
show on screen right now.
it's fucking huge and
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's sad 'cause none of the
trains stopped there either.
(Joey laughing)
There's a really...
Train that goes direct to
London but that doesn't
stop through that, and I
think it's only local trains.
- I mean, at least you have
plenty of time to read it
as you go past it.
- I wanna hear how the
train lady pronounces it.
Is it an automated message that...
(Joey laughing)
- So it's shortened to like San vide PG or
(speaking foreign language)
- Yeah. Oh yeah. I got it.
- Which is still awfully long.
- It just sounds like you
got a lot of flame circles.
- Right, right, right, but it...
Okay, the problem is even with Wales,
if you look around the rest of that map,
all the town names are just as bad.
- [Joey] Really?
- Around that area to pronounce.
I can't pronounce some
of them without taking
three minutes to look at it and be like
(speaking foreign language)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
it's kind of hard, it was a nice tangent,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like cute little town of Wales.
Don't go there, nothing there.
- [Joey] Don't go there.
- I mean, I live next to some
weird sounding places as well.
I remember when Joey came to visit,
I took him and Aki to this
place called Devil's Dyke.
- Devil's Dyke.
- I remember saying that, oh yeah,
I'm gonna take you guys to Devil's Dyke.
Aki's face was just like
(speaking foreign language)
- What did you just say?
- Because do you guys like, is Dyke...
Does the word Dyke-
- Yes.
- Have the same meaning?
- Yeah.
- So most of it is like a hill.
- But there's tons of
fucked up names in the UK.
That's like...
There's places called White
Knight and stuff like that.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, there's another place
I live next to or close to
called Cuckfield,
- [Conner] Yeah, yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Every time I drive...
Every time I'm on the train
and it goes past that,
I just have a little laugh to myself.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- There's a Cockfosters as well in London?
- Cockfosters.
- One of the main trains
stops at Cockfosters finally.
So it's like, this is
the train to Cockfosters.
- I feel like a five-year-old
every time I go on that line.
I can't remember what line it is,
- It's Piccadilly line.
- Piccadilly line, the dark
blue line. Every time I...
Because I haven't lived
in London for a few years,
every time I go on there and I hear it,
I just have to laugh.
- Burst a little smirky like none.
- I completely forgot.
- Should be those cock
fielders fucking a lot.
- There's so many that
are just like sly words.
I don't know how this is a thing.
How did we get this? How did this happen?
- We just like in Australia,
we don't have anything like
that, it's kind of sad.
We just have a lot of life.
- Special new.
- Yeah. Honestly.
And like a lot of the
names are just named off
the indigenous names.
So they sound funny, but
they're not like Cuckfield.
- I always learned by
talking to you about this
I was like, why is
there a New South Wales,
like South Wales was
never good to begin with?
Why are we making another one?
- I don't know.
- Maybe you start up from the
ground up making a good one?
- Honestly I don't know.
The only funny named place in Australia
that I know is Banana.
- Oh.
- This is a town in
Queensland called Banana,
and it has this thing
called The Big Banana,
which is the Guinness little record
for the largest banana
statue in the world.
- Why?
- Did they just name a
town after that one statue?
- Almost because also every banana
in Australia grows in Banana, Queensland.
- That part it makes more sense.
(Garnt laughing)
You should have lied with
that before you told us...
I have no idea why it's called banana.
But they just grow a lot
of bananas. It's weird.
- There's a place they grow bananas.
(Joey laughing)
And that makes a lot of it,
it's like now that you've
explained the context,
that makes a lot more sense.
- Yeah, exactly.
So we just have stuff like that,
but wish I fucking lived in
a place called Cuckfield.
That would be hilarious.
That'd be the best.
That would be the best
fucking conversations-
- Feels like you'd grow tired after all.
- Yeah. But it's like, where are you from?
Cuckfield and you immediately get along,
and it's like I've already
blended in with the conversation.
- I wish you just go to a town
in Japan when they're like
(speaking in foreign language)
- Sundei it's like you where you live now.
- Yeah.
- And you'll be like Cuckfield.
- Cuckfield.
(all laughing)
- Getting back to
- Izakayas-
- Izikayas
and Japanese matters,
- How do we come from
izakayas to Cuckfield?
- Wales, wales man.
- To me like I...
Izakayas is my number one
kind of drinking establishment
that I enjoy throughout the world,
like anywhere else-
- I mean,
it's the easiest, it's the chillest-
- It's the chillest you know.
- You always...
It's always nice, all foreigners love it
'cause it's so easy.
You press the little button-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Sometimes it's all you can drink-
- Oh yeah, 'cause you don't
have to order at the bar.
- Never have to order at the bar.
- Never order at the bar.
- I will say that is 100
times better than in the UK.
- You all order all your food
and drinks from a tablet.
There's no pressure to
get order at the bar
and they just bring it to you.
- 'Cause there is a...
One of my favorite izakayas I go to a lot
with my other friends is a...
it's one unique biko,
I don't know what it's called anymore.
It used to be called Kobayashi.
So I think I took you guys there.
I don't remember, but basically,
it's on the West side of Ikibuka,
and it's underground
and it's exactly like in izakaya,
so it has food and everything but
you pour your own drinks.
- Oh yeah, I think I've
been to that one as well.
- And there's a huge tub,
it's like a fucking
barrel full of miso shiro,
miso soup, and it's just
all you can drink miso soup,
as well as the best fucking thing ever,
'cause it's just like...
'Cause miso soup is the ultimate
hangover drink in my life.
- Yes.
- Another thing I wanna
talk about when it comes
to Japanese drinking culture is nomihodai.
- Oh yeah.
- Which is all you can drink,
which anytime someone from England
(Conner and Joey laughing)
or America or someone comes
here and they see how many...
They learn about the way
you can drink culture,
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
(Garnt clapping)
boys, I'm moving here, I'm
coming out every night.
- Every Australian I've
taken to a nomihodai
has always either been like,
so is there a drink limit?
(Garnt laughing)
Or they're like, Oh, it's
only for 10 minutes, right?
It's like happy hour, right?
It's like, no, you can do
it for as long as you want.
They are just like-
- How much is a typical nomihodai?
- That's 1500 for 30 minutes, is it?
- No.
- It's cheaper than that.
- It depends with which one you go,
either it's like-
- I've seen like 2000 yen for two hours.
- Yeah. I think it's about...
So it's about 20 bucks for two
hours of all you can drink.
- It depends where you go.
But generally it's around that price.
- Yeah, around that price.
And compared to everywhere
you see in England
and everything, that's
like a massively good deal.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Exactly. It's like, why would you not...
Even if you can't drink that much, right?
Why would you not take that?
- Even if you'd like,
I'm not at a brisk pace,
It's still good value for money.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause even like say, you
know, it's 500 yen for a beer,
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Even if you drink four
beers in the two hours,
you still getting your money's worth.
- Yeah.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- So it's like every time I'm just, Oh,
I don't really feel
like drinking that much,
but let's do nomihodai, its much-
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I remember when...
'Cause obviously when you move here,
you kind of stop wanting
all you can drink.
'Cause you're like it wears off.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But for the first few
times I visited here,
I remember thinking like...
Treating it like an Olympic event.
I'm like, all right, how
many times during the-
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- No. 'Cause that's what it
would be if there was no way
you could drink in England, right?
- Would be, yeah. That's how we think,
'cause that's how we're wired.
- You're like 80 percent
speed running izakayas.
- I was yeah, I was like
get the clock ready guys.
(all laughing)
- Time.
- I remember, I allege
she had this dilemma,
I was drinking a beer and the
first one I smashed it back,
no problem, that's easy.
Second beer I was like shit,
I'm two seconds off pace.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
but I remember...
I actually remember being like
I'm one minute off the pace
I struck myself.
(all laughing)
- Exactly the same.
You were like, how many beers do I need to
drink to make this worth?
Then how many can I go over?
You were calculating this
in your head to be like,
okay, if I drink one beer
every five to 10 minutes,
then I can smash this many beers
and I'd be earning back
this amount of money.
You know what I mean?
- [Conner] Yeah, yeah.
- You treating it like stocks.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- 'Cause this is what it is, 'cause we...
I can't remember this.
I first came here as a tourist.
We visited a bar that had 200 yen beers.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I thought, okay, that's my new baseline,
for all you can drink.
I need to make sure I
get more of my money.
(Joey laughing)
I need to make sure it's better
value than 200 yen a beer.
So I think we went to one that
was 2000 yen for two hours
and I was like, okay, in my
head, I'm working it out.
I'm like, okay..
- So that's 10 beers in 10 hours.
- Yeah, I need to get
at least 10 beers, yes.
I got to get 11 just
check, just to get it under
so I feel this was worth coming to,
and I remember I was
in so much fucking pain
on the ninth beer.
Kinda got...
'Cause we were eating as well,
and my stomach was like,
(Conner panting)
- Because I think it was eight
beers in where I was like,
I don't know if I forgot to tell you
but you can get other drinks too.
It doesn't have to be just-
- But I knew that
getting all you can drink
like spirits was playing with fire.
And I would have been on the floor.
(all laughing)
So I'm like, now I'll stick with beer
'cause beer is the natural pace.
- Now I'm gonna take you guys
to the 50 yen beer place,
because it's not an all you can drink,
but it's 50 yen-
- I'm in this 50 yen
so you might as well be
all you can get.
- Yeah, right.
- Because I feel like
that's just the difference
in mindset between
anyone from like the West
(Joey laughing)
and people in Japan.
'Cause when anyone in the West comes over
and here's all you can
drink, all you can eat,
it's the same mindset
where it's just like,
I've got a fucking speed, run this.
I've gotta optimize this.
What is the optimal speed versus trucks
(Joey and Conner laughing)
for all you can take?
And Japanese people are just like,
no we just drink however
much we feel like.
- That's the pressure
of not having to know
how much you're gonna earn.
- 'Cause I think it works
on the trust system.
'Cause I remember...
- We trust you not to
be a fucking alcoholic.
(all laughing)
- That's why this would never work
in any other country, but Japan.
- Because I remember I went
to this kind of like...
It wasn't a wine bar, what's
the place that they make wine,
what's that called?
- Winery?
- Winery, that's the place.
So I went to this winery with
Sydney, just outside of Tokyo,
and they basically had a cellar of about
a 1000 different wines.
- Right.
- And basically you could
sample as much you like,
for 10 bucks, 10 bucks you
had a cellar of a 1000 wines.
- That's gotta be some
really wrong catastrophe,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's like, if you actually go greedy
you gonna get killed.
- You going into the cellar.
- No no, it's totally right.
- So you can drink as much of
it, as you want for 10 bucks?
- Okay. So you can sample as much of it.
So every
(Conner laughing)
- Sample?
- Every-
- No, British people don't sample shakes.
- That's exactly the point.
That's exactly the point
I'm trying to make.
So I...
So me and Sydney went to being like...
The exact same mindset where it's like,
there must be a catch,
there must be a catch.
This competition-
- One of them is poison.
(all laughing)
- We go down there and they
give us this little cup,
it's the super small
cup, where you can pour,
I'd say a third of a
glass of wine into it.
- And these Japanese
people were just pouring
one little drop, like
two little drops now,
just like letting the
drop sit on their tongue.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then we were just
like, but we can draw...
We can pour however much we want, right?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
'Cause that's the thing, it's
based on the trust system.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you know, if you
want to, you can just pour
however much you want for
as many wines as you want
and no one's going to stop you, right? So-
- There's something similar to that,
that I saw in, oh fuck, where was it?
I think it was in Nagano,
when I went for a trip,
it was a sponsored trip
and at the station,
because Nagano is kind
of known for its sake,
there was exactly the same thing.
It was like 50 to like a 100 barrels
of all sorts of different sake,
and it's like yeah, again like-
- It was like water of everything?
- Yeah, it was a thousand
yen for all you can test.
- All you can test.
It's not all you can drink,
it's all you can test.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All you can sample.
And I'm just like, hell yeah.
- But there's nothing
stopping you from sampling
as much as you like, right?
- I was 20 tier in and I was like,
I'm only a fifth of the way through
so I'm about to fucking faint.
- Imagine if you can ask for a free sample
but there's no one stopping you
from asking for unlimited free samples.
(Joey laughing)
You get unlimited free samples.
That's basically the mindset.
(Joey and Conner laughing)
So it's like we're here as a westerner,
thinking we got the
fucking cheat code to this.
So, we can just like-
- It's like bottomless fries
but if you can go up
and get your own fries.
- It's like having a buff in this country.
It's like being British, the
alcohol, it's like oh shit.
- What's another establishment
that's very specific
to Japanese nightlife?
'Cause I like to think
that the karaoke nightlife?
- I mean, karaoke nightlife
here is just good as done.
It's the perfect kind
of place for karaoke.
- Because I didn't realize until recently,
but the karaoke in Japan,
is so much different
to the perception of karaoke
in Western countries.
'Cause I remember when
you, me and Felix got...
When we took Felix to a
karaoke for the first time,
he didn't wanna go.
He was kinda like, Oh, karaoke,
- Sort of cringe.
- It sounds cringe.
Because I think in his mind,
his idea of karaoke is
an open bar karaoke.
- Yeah I have-
- Which I think a lot of people think-
- I think a lot of people think,
'cause in Japan I feel like
after the Izakaya, you know,
or after going to a pub in England,
the precedence is after the
pub, you basically go clubbing.
There's no other place to go.
But in Japan,
- We'll go home and watch fun animations.
- Yeah exactly right?
But in Japan, you can just go to karaoke
and just continue the session there.
Also just hang out with your mates
and sing a bunch of songs as well.
- And it's all you can drink again.
- And again, it's all you can drink,
everywhere you go in Japan
you can get all you can drink.
It's fucking great.
- It's all you can drink and
the karaoke establishment
is open 24 hours.
- Yeah.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Which is just like a power move.
- Although I swear
whichever brand is offering,
'cause not all of them
do all you can drink.
And some of them do it for way
more expensive than others.
And I never know which fucking one it is,
so I just walk in and I'm
like, please be the cheap one.
- But that's it yeah,
that's the thing though.
You have to kind of go
around to each brand
of karaoke chain, and be like, okay,
this is the cheapest one
for all you can drink,
this is the most expensive
one for all you can drink,
so, you have to kind of be like, okay,
do I take value over
price or price over value?
- Yeah.
- Because you know that if
you go to the cheap ones,
the food is probably
gonna be not that great.
- 'Cause I've never like my entire life,
I've never really enjoyed karaoke
until I experienced karaoke in Japan.
'Cause it's not only
having a private room,
so to explain Japanese karaoke,
you have this private room,
where you can just sing as many songs
as you like that you choose,
there's no one watching you
apart from your room mates,
and you can just have fun
and sing whatever the hell you want
in the comfort of your privacy.
- They also have like
every single Western song.
So they have a selection that is like...
clips is everywhere else I've been to.
They have English songs, Chinese songs,
Korean songs and obviously Japanese songs.
- Anime songs, they got
all about anime songs.
- I was about to say
man, singing anime songs
while you're plastered as a week,
that was like...
I remember my first
experience was with Joey
and it was one of the
funnest experience ever.
It's like seeing that list
of all the anime songs,
it's like opening Pandora's box.
(Joey laughing)
You're like,
- Which one?
- Which one do I sing?
- It's like...
And then the moment he selected
fucking Tell Me Why by The Penpals.
I was just like, okay, this is my boy.
- The original Berserk,
- With the shittiest
guitar riff in existence.
I'm like, yeah, hell yeah.
Well, it's already bad in the original
but then the karaoke version was like,
oh this is so much worse,
but it's so much better.
- I was embarrassed at 3:00 AM
and we fucking destroyed that song more
than it already destroyed itself.
- We sang that song like three times.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
So you once source an outpour
like, let's do it again.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Oh my God.
I fucking miss karaoke, man.
Ever since the Rona, we
haven't really been able to-
- Go shut down for a while.
- I think it's back open though right?
From what I understand.
Yeah. But Oh man,
- It's hard to get into
that mood, you know.
- Yeah I know just like, I don't know,
I feel now that we've all
kind of been established here,
it's become a little bit more
difficult to just be like,
hey, do you wanna stay up
till 4:00 AM to go to karaoke?
- I think it's, maybe 'cause I get...
I go to bed at 12 now,
I think I get really fucking tired early.
- My sleep schedule is
a lot healthier now.
Okay. To explain another thing about
Japanese drinking culture is that
you have this ticking clock,
and it's called the last train.
And if you miss the last train,
you're staying out until 5:00 AM.
There's no...
There's basically no in-between,
either you choose to go home at like what?
11:00, 12:00?
- 11, 12ish yeah.
- 11, 11:30, which to me is like...
if it was just one hour
later or two hours later,
it would be perfect, because
after about one o'clock,
I'd be like, okay, I've
had my fun, this is cool.
I'm gonna catch the last train now.
But having to choose
between going out at 11:30,
when you were just about
getting to that point of drunk,
this that you just want to keep going,
to staying up till 5:00 AM,
which we've done it several times,
and every time I just
feel more dead inside,
the night after that.
- There's nothing worse...
I think the only thing that is worse
than going home while
you're buzzed at 11:00 PM
is catching that first train at 4:30.
It's just fucking like
(Joey yelling)
- It's like sunny outside and then
this businessman next to you,
you're clearly a fucking mess.
- You just turn into a fucking vampire.
Just like, the sun, no.
- I fucking fell asleep one time
and missed my stop by an hour.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I woke up at 6:00 AM, so fucking north.
- Like the end of the line, right?
- Yeah, yeah. I think I was
an hour and a half from Tokyo.
- Yeah, yeah.
I tell far I'd gone and
I was like get back.
And I was so fucking done.
It was 6:30 AM when I
realized and I was like,
nooooo.
(Garnt laughing)
So one of the sleep.
- Yeah.
- I Mean, that's the tough thing, man.
I mean, that's the thing like back when
I was still single and kind of going out
and doing a lot more of
the 4:00 AM 5:00 AM stuff,
It would be a little bit
easier because, you know,
say like a couple of my
friends will be like,
it'd be like, you know, one or 2:00 AM.
I'd be like, ah, maybe we
shouldn't continue anymore.
It was really easy because you
could just go to Ammonia Cafe
and just book a fucking
room for two, three hours,
you just fucking sleep in
there until the first train.
And that's it so, but
we haven't done that,
we should do that more often.
Instead I'll just be
like let's call up a taxi
and spend a hundred bucks to get home.
- I've always known that
you can do the Mung cafes.
I just don't wanna have that
conversation at 3:00 AM,
smashed to some Japanese
dude and I'm like,
(speaking foreign language)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It should just be like,
sleep two hours, let me in.
(all laughing)
It's a monkey brand and they'll be like,
okay we get it, we understand.
- Maybe, every single time was like
I'll just wait until 5:00 AM.
- Yeah, we should just
do that from now on.
If we're having like a boys' night,
we'd just be like, I don't want it.
'Cause sometimes I don't
wanna spend a hundred bucks
to fuck-
- Coffee?
- If we are all going back the same way.
It's not split in two ways.
- I mean, yeah, I guess, still it's like
you still feel like shit, my heart.
- What is wrong with my side?
What is this clown destroying me?
(all laughing)
- The clown is just getting to you.
- Fuck. It's fighting my monkeyness.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- The clown is taking over.
- This video is sponsored by Express VPN.
- I know most of you
are probably thinking,
why don't I just use incognito mode?
Wrong gun, you can't watch Hentai in
incognito mode, or clear
your browser history
as many times as you
want. It doesn't work.
- Well, you mean people actually know
what Hentai I am watching?
(Conner laughing).
- They can see?
- The FBI possibly knows
if they have an entrance.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Your Internet Service Provider can see
every single website that you visit.
That's why I never go online
without using Express VPN.
- It doesn't matter where
you get your internet from,
whether it be Comcast, Verizon
or any other US ISPs,
they can still legally
sell all your information to ad companies.
- I'm also told that Express VPN keeps all
of your information 100% safe,
with the most powerful
encryption available,
not that I would know any
of the other encryptions.
- Express VPN is also available
on multiple platforms.
You can have it on your phone,
you could have it on your
computer, tablet, Smart TV,
wherever you use the internet,
Express VPN is there.
- I actually do use it and
it's actually really seamless.
It's this is just a single button press in
my little monkey brain, works great.
- Do you notice it when it's on?
- No, never.
(Joey laughing)
I use it all the time
and I do often forget
that I've put it on as it
doesn't really affect much.
- I use it a lot actually to
get around geo restrictions
for Netflix and stuff like that.
Sometimes there are some
movies you just can't watch
on Japanese Netflix, so I
just pop, press a button,
it's on, and you get around that shit.
- It's also the number
one rated VPN service
by CNET and wired.
- So you can visit our exclusive link at
expressvpn.com/TrashTaste
get a free extra three months
for free on a one year package.
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S vpn.com/trashtaste.
- Now back to the episode.
- You know what I love about
karaoke the most though.
(Joey burping)
- Sorry, the clown juice.
(Garnt laughing)
- Fucking ulcers?
- Oh it's hidden. It's hidden.
(Garnt laughing)
- So, on top of the all you can drink,
sometimes they have like
other stuff that you can have,
like drink and eat, unlike soft drinks,
but they might have like soup, sometimes-
- What?
- An ice cream.
- I know the ice cream, I
don't know about the soup.
- You know that fucking time when you guys
were kind of stopped eating
so much fucking ice cream?
- 'Cause they came back
with like two fucking
packets of ice cream.
- So they had like small,
tiny cups and bowls
for this ice cream, and I
was like, no, I'll take one
of the big cup glass and fucking pull
all the ice cream in there.
Must have refilled it
like three or four times.
- That's so much ice cream.
- But I was just sitting
there the whole time
at karaoke, sitting there,
(Joey laughing)
just, oh I'm good, you go next.
- I remember when I saw
the ice cream machine next
to the soft drink machine,
- Who the fuck would get that?
(all laughing)
- But I remember that I'm
thinking like I'm a...
We don't need that, we need alcohol.
And then two hours
later, fucking plastered.
I'm like,
(sipping dry air)
cock fluid, cock fluid,
that was amazing right now.
- That ice cream looks so good right now.
- It is pretty garbage
vanilla ice cream bar.
But when you're that drunk, it's like-
- You can drink anything.
- But anything that's
bottled at that point.
(Joey laughing)
You know what I'll say like in Japan,
it just goes along with the nightlife.
It's the UConn drinks.
(Joey and Garnt nodding)
- John explained that
UConn drink because that..
- So I should have
bought one in preparation
if we can talk about this,
but there's these tiny little things,
like 200 milliliter cans.
- It's like that big.
- It's like a medicine bottle.
- Yeah yeah and it tastes like bubble gum
and it's apparently like
ginger, like it's ish ish.
- That it taste bubble gum
I think it tastes like,
- I think it tastes-
- I think it tastes great.
- [Meilyne] Turmeric.
- Turmeric.
- Just like ginger.
- Thank you Meilyne.
- But yeah, it tastes like-
I liked the taste-
- [Conner] Do you like the taste?
- I like the taste.
- Felix liked the taste.
- Yeah, but Felix is fucking weird.
- It reminds me of Calpol,
that's why I like the taste.
- So essentially, what
this drink is advertised
as is prevents hangovers,
and everyone of the Western world is like,
that doesn't seem right.
- Well, I first saw it-
- That was like a scam.
- When I first saw it, I was like,
I'm pretty sure if it
worked, we would have like...
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That was my thoughts
as well. Like how...
If it really works, why
has England not used it?
- Don't you think the
entire budget of the NHS
would be spent on buying this
because then all of the medical
problems would be solved?
I'm pretty sure we would
have it right here,
but then I thought, one
day on a whim, I was like,
all right, fine, I'll try it.
And then it was like having
a shield on your liver,
not like none of the drinks got me drunk.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And it was like that
for the first few times
until I really drank way too much.
And then it was like, not
drunk, not drunk, not drunk,
absolutely unable to sleep, like not.
It's so weird.
- It was just like the 2020 economy.
It was just like the Coronavirus tank,
and then you're fucking
drunk in like an instant.
Because I never tried it
until tried it with you,
because every time I
saw it, I was like, no.
Maybe that will work for like one drink,
but I don't go to an
izakaya and have one drink.
So I'm like, no, this won't work for me.
But then yeah, I had it and
it tastes awesome, like great.
This is already good stock.
And then yeah, I think I was
like four or five drinks in,
- And you don't feel like anything.
- And I'm just like, Oh my God,
- It's weird.
- The immunity.
- So it's advertises it like
you don't have a hangover,
but really I think it's
like format alchemists.
It's like lava equivalent exchange, right?
(Joey laughing)
- I know what I'm talking about.
- So you drink it and you
lose your fucking mother.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You drink it and you get
less drunk when you drink it.
So you have to drink more to get drunk.
But the day after, if you did
completely destroy your body
I feel like it doesn't help the hangover.
- If you go too hard, it doesn't help.
But you know there's
times where maybe you've
had quite a bit, you're quite tipsy,
you're not absolutely shit-faced,
it completely stops any hangovers.
- Yeah. Please stop saying hangover,
but for me it stops that
tipsy feeling as well.
- Yeah. In my mind, when it
comes to whether it gets rid
of the hangover the next morning,
I feel like a lot of it is just placebo,
where it's just like if I drink this,
it'll probably stop it.
- I definitely feel an effect.
- Yeah. Because at the hangovers,
the worst hangovers I've had in Japan,
is when I haven't drank that.
So now I've pretty much
like you'll never see me
go drinking without drinking it now,
which I don't know if
it's a good thing or not?
Is my body gonna get
dependent on it to drink?
'Cause like anything?
- I always drink it when
I know I have something
to do the next day.
- It's not bad for you by the way.
It's literally just like turmeric
or ginger.
- If anything
it's very healthy by the way.
- It's just a bunch of
fucking minerals and shit,
I fucking know it, like I...
Look at me, I'm a monkey brain,
like I know what's in it,
I don't question this shit.
- Just look it up and you'll find it,
but yeah, from what I understand it,
it's very healthy, it's
like a health drink.
- Someone's gonna call it
and be like, actually it's-
- Actually, it destroys your liver.
It's like as if the
alcohol doesn't already
destroy the liver.
- Actually, hidden health benefits,
hidden health benefits of course.
(all laughing)
- What do you...
How do you boys feel about clubbing?
Because I've not been to
a club in Japan before.
- Have you been to a Koch club?
- Yeah. I've been to a few, but
I've never enjoyed clubbing.
Even back in Australia, it
was just never really a thing.
I like bars, but I don't like clubs.
- I really like bars,
but I don't like clubs.
I feel like, okay, here's my theory.
I feel like clubbing is
this place that everyone's
convinced themselves they enjoy
when they really don't enjoy.
Like it's...
clubbing is one massive lie.
I don't know anyone who
actually enjoys clubbing,
'cause the only time you enjoy clubbing
is if you're massively plastic.
- If you actually enjoy clubbing,
you're someone I don't wanna talk to.
- The people I know who enjoy clubbing
are normally the ones who I just don't
like hanging out with.
(all laughing)
I know I'm not gonna like...
- They are like the epitome of oh my God.
They always talk like that.
- It's like clubbing is like...
clubbing is great when
you're young, I guess,
but then you reach a certain
point until a few years past,
then you realize, man, I
never really enjoy clubbing,
I was just lying to myself.
All I do when I go to a club,
is go in, see the dance floor,
order a drink, go dancing
for like five minutes,
realize I'm still too sober,
go order another drink,
and then that cycle repeats.
- When to repeat, yeah.
- Until you're fucking drunk enough
to not remember the night.
And if you do remember the
night it's a shit night.
- Yeah, why?
- And it hurts 'cause
you gotta pay entry fee,
and then you gotta pay
double the price for a drink.
So if you're not drunk
enough, it's like fuck,
not only am I having a shit time,
my wallet is taking a financial beating.
- Clubs are fuss, man, they're a lie.
- I'll tell you the only
times clubbing is fun,
But can I tell the story
about the last time
we went clubbing?
- Sure, sure. Go ahead, go ahead.
- Okay, I gotta hear this.
- I feel like the only time
clubbing is actually fun
is when the night is unplanned.
When you don't plan to go to a club,
I feel like the spontaneous
clubbing nights are the best
'cause you're already really
drunk and in the mood,
when you just suddenly
decide to go to a club.
So last time I actually went
clubbing was over a year ago,
with a...
And it was with Conner and
two of my mates, right?
And it was just a spontaneous
kind of clubbing nights
where we didn't even plan to go clubbing,
we just wanted to go hit up some bars,
and then we got massively twice.
- Did we? I think we were
just sitting at your house
and we were just gonna do that,
and then I think something boiled up
and you were like, clubbing?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I think we were like...
We were sitting in the
house and we were just going
to have it like a chilled night.
- And you were telling
stories about clubbing.
We were telling stories
about clubbing and I think
eventually we were like,
should we just go clubbing?
(all laughing)
- Yeah. 'Cause I remember
we hit up a bar before hand,
and we were pretty married at that point.
We weren't super drunk,
and then we got to the bar, I think it was
Absolute VOD Green Brighton or something,
and we just ordered three
of those 14 shot trays,
- Oh my God!
- And we got drunk very, very fast,
but the person who got drunk
the most, was this guy.
(Garnt pointing at Conner)
- I think I had like one of
the whole 14 shots to myself.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And like, bear in mind
I think I was just...
Excuse us sweetheart.
At the time, I'd just broke up with my ex
and I was like, I just wanna go out.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I just wanna do something,
I wanna get out of here.
I was like I just want to party
and then when I went away.
- So what was the last
memory you had of that night?
- I remember waiting in line for the club.
Alcohol abusive badge by the way.
- Yeah, we don't condone this.
This is a story, not condoning...
- We're laughing about it
but we don't condone it.
- I've rarely...
Rarely do I get that drunk where
I don't remember exactly what happened,
which I always speak to
Americans like that sounds scary.
I'm like, yeah, I'm in
the company of my mates,
you know they'll take care of me.
- So, after the bar,
we clearly realized how drunk
Conner was, but we still...
It was still pretty early in the night,
it was like 10 o'clock, 10:30.
(Conner and Joey laughing)
The club had just opened.
That's kind of the timing
we're talking about.
And we just kind of...
We were like, okay, before the
alcohol gets Conner anymore,
we gotta fuck again this
club, as soon as possible,
so we line up just as
the club was opening...
- Someone said fucking
Wednesday or something.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
No one was clubbing. No one, just us.
- We all worried about how
Conner was gonna get in,
'cause he was clearly
over the fucking limit.
And if you know UK clubs, if
you look like you're too drunk,
they're just not gonna
let you in, bouncers...
Bouncers in UK are like the school bully,
they're like...
They will take advantage
of any power they have.
So we were fucking worried.
So, somehow Conner...
We managed to get Conner in this club.
- This is the best heist by the way.
- Yeah. So we must get
Conner in and we're like,
Oh, that's this is it, we've done it.
- The mission impossible thing-
- We've done mission impossible.
Yeah, yeah.
So, then we go over to the bar,
as you do in the clubbing experience
the first thing you go to is the bar.
- Of course.
- And then we go to order our drinks.
And so I'm here with two of my mates
and we each order a drink,
and then we look around
and Conner is just not there.
We are like, wait, if
you're not with Conner,
and you're not with Conner
and I'm not with Conner,
then where the fuck's Conner?
And then we turn around, and
look at this empty dance floor,
and Conner is just standing
there, at a 90 degree angle.
He's like this.
(Garnt bending at 90 degree angle)
(Joey and Conner laughing)
(Joey clapping)
All right, and we are like,
oh shit we better get him
off the dance floor.
And then like as a walking over,
he starts fucking Fortnite
dancing by himself
on the dance floor.
(all laughing)
- You know you gotta do, you gotta do it.
- And so the bouncer
sees this and obviously,
Conner's way over the limit.
So, he gets kicked out and
so, we also have to follow him
out of the club.
So we're like, do we attempt another club?
It's only like 10:30.
Let's try and attempt another club,
thinking we're not gonna get in.
Somehow, Conner by pure instincts,
he's like, he can't even
walk to this next club.
But as soon as he's standing in line,
he's like, yes gentlemen.
- I did a why when I'm drunk.
For some reason I can
just like for 30 seconds,
I can be like,
(Conner inhaling and
flexing his back muscles)
yes of course I am.
(Joey and Darnt laughing)
Like I dunno why, its super power.
- Yeah. When you're...
When he's in front of the bouncer,
he just turns it to proper Seadog VA.
(all laughing)
- The monkey brain
unlocks into human brain.
- Somehow we...
We somehow get him into the second club.
And the same fucking thing happens again.
(Joey and Conner laughing)
We go into the bar, and
then we take our eyes
off Corner for one second, order a drink,
I look around, look to my
left, look to my right,
if you're not with Conner,
and if you're not with Conner,
and then we turn around, and once again,
Conner on an empty dance floor
is just Fortnite dancing by himself.
- Is that just like an
instinct for you to dance?
- I think so, I think it
must be I like dancing.
I don't know why Fortnite
dancing must be my go-to.
I don't know.
(joey and Garnt laughing)
- And so we get kicked out of that club
and that was the end of the night.
- It's Good night.
It's Good night.
- Yeah.
He woke up snug.
- Don't get drunk.
Yeah. We got him back home.
I took him on the bed and he
just slides snuggling side
the saggy pillow and yeah,
that's what he woke up with.
All the instincts giving you a lockdown.
- Yeah. I woke up and I was like,
where is my phone and wallet?
(Joey laughing)
Where is it? And it
was just under the bed.
But I was like...
That was the first five
minute panic of mine.
I was like, where is this?
- Oh my God.
So you don't remember any of that?
- I remember some of it, but not much.
I mean, that was pretty
the most drunk I've gotten
in a very long time.
I'd rarely ever get that drunk,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But you know, sometimes
you fuck up and do a lot
of vodka and yeah.
- It happens, man.
'Cause it's like, you've been
clubbing in Japan, right?
- Yeah, yeah I have.
- What's that like?
How is it compared to
the rest of the world?
- It's just like...
At least compared to the UK, and the UK
I felt like everyone in
the club is very drunk.
And in Japan I felt like everyone
was in the same situation
of, I need to be drunk,
which makes a pretty
shitty club environment
'cause everyone's kind
of sober and it's weird.
Like it's...
- No one wants to like step out of line.
- Yeah, it's weird.
Like no one's doing anything fun except
for somehow, everyone
is really well-behaved.
And somehow the moment
you step into the toilet,
it was like a war zone in that toilet.
I don't know what happened.
There was a dude who was like pissing,
and he was not even aiming in the urinal.
He was aiming at the wall next to it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
and he was spraying, and
I walked in and I'm like
I'm not getting blamed for this.
I'm walking out, 'cause I
know this guy was Japanese.
I'm like, I'm not fucking with it.
I don't want to be blamed for this.
I'm not doing it.
- I'm the minority in this club.
(all laughing)
- I'm like, I'm the foreigner here.
I looked at him, I'm
walking out right now.
But yeah, there, it was so filthy,
but the rest of the club was just fine.
It was whatever, it was
just a depressing situation.
I'd rather have been smashed
Fortnite dancing alone,
any day of the week.
- Yeah. That's kind of a
similar experience I had.
I went to one club in Japan.
And that was enough for
me to be like, yeah,
I mean, I never really enjoyed clubs
when I was like, you know what?
I'm living here, I might
as well give it a go.
I just wasn't it.
- I felt like everyone was doing it
'cause they've seen it
in the movies there.
I don't know what. I was
like, this is cool, right?
We cool right now.
Like, wait, we've seen
this in the movies, right?
- This is exactly how
we're supposed to behave.
- 'Cause I think the most different
clubbing experience I've
had is probably in Thailand.
Well, they have like, I don't like...
I like their clubbing culture even less.
Because they don't even
have a dance floor.
So, some clubs in Thailand,
it's you go in and there's no dance floor
but everyone has their own tables.
But the music is just as
loud as any other club.
(Conner laughing)
So try and so...
So you're sitting around-
- Such a loud restaurant.
- This is the wild bar.
- So you're sitting at...
Everyone has his private tables.
So you can't even like...
It's not a social
environment where you can go
meet other people or even
interact with other people,
you're with your mates, but
it's so loud that you can't
communicate with your mates,
So all you're doing is sitting
in this loud fucking room.
I must sound like such an old guy now.
The music was too loud, this was awful.
But no,
- No, too far. When the music is too loud,
it's like my biggest pet peeve.
- I've been in some clubs in Australia
where the bass is so fucking bass boosted
that you can actually
feel your chest going
(Joey clutching his chest)
dude like this while you're sitting there.
I was like, hey, how are you?
- That voice is so bassy
as well than in clubs,
I could just cannot communicate like-
- It's just extravagant.
- I remember university, if I
ever tried to hit on someone,
they'd just be like, what
are you saying, you know,
are you talking to me?
- Do you have that thing
where you're trying
to say something to your
mate, but it's so loud,
or your mates trying
to say something to you
and it just sounds like
a blah, blah, blah.
And you're like sorry,
can you say that again?
You do it three times as the magic number,
and then the third time you are like,
Oh yeah, yeah, definitely.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'll be like yeah, I
don't know, I don't know.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I have nothing to say.
- That's just yeah.
That's just the clubbing
experience, I guess.
- I mean, we personally don't
recommend clubs in Japan,
but I mean...
- I mean, if that's your
stick that's your stick.
- But we don't...
I think we've made it clear
that we don't really like
clubbing anyway, so why
don't we gonna enjoy clubbing
in Japan?
- The reason I like izakayas
is that 'cause it's the
perfect social environment,
because I like talking to people.
I like house parties, I
like house parties a lot.
And I've always...
In university, if there was a
choice between a clubbing...
Going clubbing and going to a house party,
I'm like a hundred percent of the time
I'm choosing the house party,
'cause I like talking to people and I feel
like the izakaya vibe is
just that perfect vibe
that just like you, it allows
you to talk to your mates.
- There's also that
element of a house party.
It's like, are they gonna
fuck up their own house?
If so, I wanna be there to watch this.
(all laughing)
- What's like the craziest house parties
you guys have been to?
(all laughing)
- I've got like two and they
were both in university.
Of course they were.
- Yeah of course they were.
- Do you have one?
- I can only really think of like-
- I have one if you want me to go first.
- There's a lot of like poop stories
but I'm like,
- More poop? Noooo!
- This is where the poop
stories are coming in.
- All of my poop stories
come from house parties.
- What? Whose plan?
- Like, okay...
So in Australia, Oh my God.
Another thing I think about
it, it's as fucking disgusting.
But..
- Oh no.
- But do you know what a shoey is?
- That's where you do
the beer out of the shoe.
- Yes. So it's this
thing that's very typical
in Australia because there's
nothing as fucking good.
- Why is this typical in Australia?
- Typical house party shit we do
in Australia.
- The local cuisine.
- The local cuisine of the shoey,
but essentially what it is, is you...
It's kind of like shotgunning
in America, right?
Where, shotgunning is like, you know,
if someone's holding a can of beer
they're like, Oh, shotgun it.
So you poke a hole on the side
and then you kind of drink
the whole thing like this.
Shoey is that, but way grosser.
You say, hey, do a shoey,
and then you go around,
the tradition is you go around
and find whoever has the
dirtiest fucking shoe.
- Ooooh.
It's not just any shoe, it's
whoever has the dirty shoe.
It's either you do your own shoe
or you pick whoever's
has the dirtiest shoe.
- This is already starting horribly.
- And then you grab this
shoe, you pull the can of beer
into their shoe and then you
drink the beer from their shoe.
- That's disgusting, that's..
- And I mean, it's not
that exciting of a story
but my friend did a shoey once
and he got his friends a
shoe and he didn't realize
until after he finished the shoey
that he had stepped on his dog shit.
(Garnt laughing)
- So he had like a firm grasp?
- He had a firm grasp of
it and he finished it,
and he's like, he flipped it
over and just saw like shit,
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
just smeared on that shoe.
- It's so disgusting.
- And like normal people will
be like, Oh, what the fuck?
But because he was already so hammered,
he's just like yeah.
(all laughing)
And everyone was like yeeee!
This is fucking nasty.
That's the only thing really.
And then other than that,
it's just like a lot of vomit stories,
you know the usual that
you hear at house parties.
Yeah. I mean, yeah.
That was probably the grossest.
- God that's
disgusting.
- But also the most hilarious.
- Oh my God.
- All right. Where are you
going with some of them?
- I mean, I've been to like
a few crazy house parties.
I think most of the crazy
house parties I've been to
has been in Brighton.
So that's where like my hometown.
There are some parties
that are just like...
Kind of like, you know that
scene from American pie,
where you see that senior,
like there's no way there
that exists in real life.
There's no way this
crazy shit's happening.
But yeah, I've been to a few parties
where he was actually that crazy.
So I remember one time,
where there was this party
who we'd heard from a friend,
who heard from another friend,
now that kind of thing
- Sounds like being in a horror story.
- There was a party happening
in the middle of this field.
I'm just like, there's no
fucking way this is true.
So we had to drive into the
middle of fucking nowhere.
And I was like, this is a scam,
we're gonna drive there, and
there's just gonna be like...
It's just gonna be like
a drug dealer den or so.
Or this is gonna be like...
We're gonna get fucking murdered.
And so we drive to the
middle of this field,
and keep in mind, this is all pitch black,
'cause it's like the
middle of the countryside,
where we're driving
to, so we can see shit,
and then we go there and it
was basically like a festival,
somehow they had managed to...
Because this guy who had owned the farm,
had just told a few of his mates
that he was gonna have a party,
and then mates started
telling mates and then...
- It's always the worst.
- Yeah. I don't know how
it's spreads so wide.
- Jesus!
- But I feel like it's because
no one else is having a party that weekend
and people were just
egging, and people were just
very much ready to go to somewhere.
- I just want to go to a party guys.
- I need to do a party.
- And yeah. Somehow there
was a fucking festival.
And then things started getting weird.
They started setting things on fire.
So, they went into his house,
- Right.
and then they took out the sofa
and somebody thought it
would be a fun idea to
just start burning stuff.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
So it started off-
- Why is always there one
person that just burns things?
- I don't know, there's always one pyro...
One fucking pyromaniac.
(Joey laughing)
And so, first it starts with the chair.
So they get a chair out,
and like, okay, let's set this on fire.
And it's like fucking
cave man mood activates.
Like whenever you start
a fire, for some reason,
you see fire, and then you're like,
- Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
- And then you start fucking
dancing around it like,
woo, woo fire.
(Garnt dancing)
I dunno why whenever there's a fire
and there's a house party and
there was alcohol involved,
you just forget...
The lizard brain just takes over,
and you just like circling, just watch it.
And then...
So they burned the chair
down, and they were like,
what could we do next?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What could we do next?
let's get a table. So, I don't know...
- Where do you just take this
guy's whole fucking Ikea collection?
My Jesus Christ.
- Then they take a table,
they set down fire,
then as that's on fire,
a fucking sofa appears out of nowhere,
and then they fucking
just shot the sofa in.
And then, we were just like...
At the back of my mind, I'm thinking, man,
the host must feel so fucking shit,
I dunno where he's probably
plastered out of his mind.
- Oh my furniture has been burnt.
- And then as the sofa is on fire,
we actually see the host just walk out,
and he just looks at his sofa,
and his fucking Ikea furniture
connection that's on fire.
And just goes, yeeeeeh!
- What if right, what if all along,
he planned this out, right?
Because in the UK, if you wanna
get rid of stuff like that,
you've got to pay a lot.
So maybe this was all applaud,
just so he could get new sofas and shares
not pay to remove his old ones.
- Yeah. There's always also
that one guy in any kind
of situation like that,
where something's put on fire
where they're holding
an alcoholic beverage
and they're like, I wonder
what happens if I pour it all?
(Garnt laughing)
It's like this the point I put it out.
It just makes the flame bigger.
It's like, Oh, I wasn't expecting that.
Okay. Every time, every fucking time.
- Animals, animals.
- Yeah, fucking cavemen.
- There is...
So you know how I said I
lived in a student village?
- Yeah.
- It was basically a whole
area that was just houses.
And there had also two
really big apartment blocks
and they were disgusting.
They are the cheapest apartment
blocks you can imagine.
And one time people...
This doesn't exist anymore, this place,
they tore it all down.
So, yes. Once the student village RIP,
they said, Oh yeah,
there's gonna be a party
at one of the apartment buildings.
They didn't say which floor or anything,
so I thought that was kind of weird.
And then we turn up, and half
of this apartment building,
there's bin bags on all
the windows and stuff.
- [Garnt] -Right.
- [Joey] - Right.
And then you started
going into this building,
and it's been turned into
like the set of the raid.
There's just shit everywhere.
There's mattresses on the floor and shit.
All over the place, and
some of the rooms are open
and have nothing left in them.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
And meanwhile, everyone is drunk as fuck,
there's people doing
drugs in certain places,
people in the kitchen,
there's always that one guy
who is in the kitchen making food
for somebody in all these parties.
Like this building is
literally like falling apart,
and one guy is standing there.
Anyone wants beans? Any
beans that you want?
It was just weird, and it was
like the further up you went,
there like more of a mess, it was...
And I remember going to one floor
and there was just beds all over it,
and people lying down and I'm like
what the fuck is going on here?
That was just weird.
And then I just didn't enjoy it.
Some are like just what is this?
- Wait, wait, so it was
an orgy floor or what?
- I didn't stay long enough.
- How did you get invited into this party?
- It was one of those
things where everyone
just everyone knew it was
happening in the village.
So we all just turned up it's the village.
- Word around the village,
is that this building.
- And I was like why did you put
(speaking in foreign language)
Why did they put bin bags on the windows?
And they were like, Oh,
so they can't see what's going on inside.
But I'm like, who, who can't see?
Because they think putting black window...
Like blacking out all the
windows is suspicious in a way.
That's what I thought.
And also a bunch of people
migrating towards this one thing
they completely fucked it though.
I don't know what happened to it
or how this was even possible.
I'm sure the owner-
- I mean the fact that it's gone now-
- Yeah, yeah. It's true, it's true.
And then there was another party,
which was really weird
and it was a house party,
like just a normal
house and had a bouncer?
Which I thought was really weird.
- At a house?
- At a house party.
- And I wondered-
- What's the fucking motive?
- Right, right.
So it was a three storey
house, not that big,
but I thought, wow, this is fucking weird.
There's a bouncer and he's a list.
I said my name is and he is
like, you're on the list.
I'm like, when do I get put on the list?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- What is this List?
- Who's arranging this list
'cause my friend invited me.
So he must have put me on the list.
Then I got inside, the
first floor just is like
a big living room,
just has one small couch in the corner,
and like a hundred people
just standing around this,
very average looking
laminated-like wood floor,
just the people standing around
and I'm like, what the fuck?
Why is there a bouncer?
And then you go up the floors
and it starts to get weird,
as of course it doesn't if you got floors
in these weird house parties
I remember asking...
I found out that...
But I asked my friend
and he was like, Oh yeah,
I paid them out so like 300
pounds just for tonight.
And I'm like, why?
- Why?
- What would you expecting to happen?
- Are you that worried?
And then, okay, okay. To be fair...
And then I realized why he
was that worried because
the second floor was
just people having sex.
- It was actually pretty standard.
- That's pretty standard,
that's pretty standard.
I was like, whatever,
and I was like, okay,
maybe we were in shock.
'Cause the bottom floor
was just really loud.
And I'm like, maybe I wanna go
to the floor where people
were just chatting.
Right. So I go to the third floor,
and that's where it gets
really fucking weird
'cause one of the rooms is like,
I thought it was like
five beds, two bunk beds
and instead they just put all
the mattresses on the floor.
I don't know why people are doing this.
All the mattresses were on the floor,
and people were making out
and one of them had like...
Was doing like a needle, I
don't know what he was doing.
And I was like, Oh, this is weird.
This is really fucking weird.
I'm not going here, and so I was like...
I asked my friend, I'm like,
there's gotta be somewhere else we can go.
I do not wanna stay here.
There's someone doing what
I think is heroin upstairs.
Can we not do this?
University's a mess.
- Jesus Christ.
I'd never had any like that.
'Cause I hung out with
good Christian boys.
- Obviously, so do I, but
sometimes you go to a party.
You hear about a party, you don't know
what it's gonna be like
till you get there.
Until you see someone doing
like hardcore drugs upstairs
and you're like, I'm
not supposed to be here,
I don't do this.
- I need to go to church.
- Yeah. Most of the house parties,
the more stairs you go up
it's like the closer you get to hell.
(Joey laughing)
It's like the steps towards hell.
- It's literally the rate.
- It's like the opposite, right?
It's like the further up you go,
the closer you get to hell.
- It's awful 'cause I
mean, you have no way
of knowing in the UK what
the party is gonna be like
till you get there.
So, if your friend's dead set on going,
you're like alright fine.
- Because I've been to
as many Dodd parties,
where you go to and it's
like, this isn't a party,
this is a house gathering.
With like prettied up.
We prettied up.
- Right, right. You never know...
I never know, a party could mean like
a come dine with me,
four people making dinner
for each other experience
or it could be, you know,
a vagan orgy going on upstairs.
You don't know till you get there.
No one knows, my parents
were probably terrified
they're like what was
Conner doing in university?
I was not doing anything, mother.
I was just...
You happen to go to places
and they fucked up.
- Yeah. It's funny because I did...
I had less crazy parties in university,
but that might just be because
of the university I went to,
which was University of Bristol,
and because it's like a city campus,
it's like University Bristol
was in the middle of the city,
there was less going on
because it was all...
Like we're integrated
with the normal people,
- Yeah.
- [Conner] Yeah, yeah.
- The normal working people,
so, you can get away with less shit
than if it was on like a campus.
- Yeah. Mine was kind of the same
'cause Sydney uni was in
my the smack bang middle
of the city center in Sydney, so, I mean,
there was always weird
shit that were happening
like the smaller campuses,
but nothing like that.
- There was just so many rundown places.
So it was like, sometimes I think
like locals would like see a party
and then just like go in.
- Just go in.
- Yeah. I think that happened a lot.
- And that makes sense.
- That's why I would
never throw a house party
that just let anyone in.
- No.
- I don't know how fucked up this is.
Bro, talk about the trust system, bro.
(all laughing)
That's just like the other
end of the stupid truck.
- I remember if you were having a party,
and you told your close mates,
especially in my school,
'cause this was before
I went to university,
but in like college, if there was a party,
everyone would...
Everyone in fucking Brighton
would know know about it.
- Yeah.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Somehow. You know word would get out
and I would not throw a party,
especially on a day, like New Year's eve,
where everyone's searching for a party.
- People just rock up.
I mean, that's kind of
why Chicano don't go
to open invite house parties anymore.
'Cause like after seeing that I'm like,
that's just too much, that's...
I'm not signing up for that,
I don't need that in my mind.
- Yeah, it's like if I
wanted to go to a house party
and like four fits of people
there, are people I don't know,
I'd rather just go to
a club ,at that point.
It's basically...
It becomes the same thing right?
- Yeah. But clubs are pretty bad,
but at least as not people doing like,
fucking hardcore without condom,
on the dance floor, probably
in the toilet, that's them.
I don't care.
- Call on Conner, even Fortnite dance.
(Garnt laughing)
- Fortnite dance without
people judging me,
- And me in the orgy
room Fortnite dancing.
(all laughing)
All the mattresses a
dance floor dance, right?
I'll have a dance.
(all laughing)
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- My God. But have you
guys ever been to the...
I know it's a property like tourist trap,
whatever it's considered,
but the Golden Gai in Shinjuku,
- Oh yeah, I've been.
- And how did you like it?
- No.
- They are not really your thing?
- Not really because...
- You wanna explain more Golden Gai is?
- Yes the Golden Gai is like this.
Fuck, what it's like? 40 by
40 meters area, if you will.
And it's just like a series of
alleyways, extremely compact.
- Its not even a block, it's
within the block, isn't it?
- Yeah, it's tiny and it's bars all seat
max three to four people, sometimes two
depending on where you go,
and it's really expensive.
You pay sometimes 10
bucks just to sit down
and then you only pay
10 bucks for a drink.
And yeah, it's a tourist trap.
'Cause a lot of the time it's tourists,
and also it's a very sketchy area.
And if you are a foreigner,
there will be a guy
who is very much watching you,
and the moment they see you're foreign,
they'll come up to you, that's
really fucking frustrating.
'Cause sometimes it's-
- I went in there once,
just 'cause I wanted
to take my friend who
had never been there.
So I was like, okay, I'll experience it.
And yeah, I was just like, man,
this is just like a really cramped,
super expensive drinking experience
like you can get anywhere else in Tokyo
- It's like if you see pictures of it,
which probably won't be on screen now,
it's kind of like
cyberpunk house-cloud like-
- I love going to Golden
Gai just to take photos.
- It's like that cyber punk aesthetic,
where you just got these all...
A lot of these buildings
and a lot of these bars
just crammed together,
and you don't even know how
anyone could live in there,
let alone operate a business in here.
- 'Cause I can't imagine any of these bars
getting maybe more than 10
people at cost, a night.
- It depends there's
one or two of the bars
that would do something big,
but most of them are, yeah, very small.
- I mean, there'll be a few big ones
outside of Golden Gai
right before you enter it,
near the entrance.
But once you actually go into Golden Gai,
it's like, how do any of
these places stay open?
- I think it's you...
I think you go to Golden
Gai to meet other people.
You don't go there with your...
You can go there with your mates.
- But you can also meet
other people anywhere else.
- But this is kind of
vibe to it that's like,
because it's so small, you
immediately have to talk
to anyone who's next to you.
You don't really have a choice.
Like in the rest of Tokyo,
you kind of got your way
and be like, hi, you
wanna know about my cult?
Like you got to like really-
- That's right, that's right.
- Yeah. You gotta seem
like a little weird, right?
'Cause you have...
But in this bar, you know, you sit down,
you're immediately next to someone
and you just start trying to communicate.
And yeah, the one time
I went it was 'cause...
We used to staying right
next to it funny enough.
And I think it was one night where
it's my second to last night in Japan,
my first time visiting, I think Joey,
Joey like gone and Allen
didn't wanna hang out,
and now I was like, well,
I wanna do something
so, I Googled on my, where can I go?
And then, this was the
only place that came up
and I was like, all right, fine.
I'd never heard of it before.
I didn't know it was a tourist tracker.
So I just went there and
yeah, it was really fun.
I mean, met a ton of people and
then eventually made friends
with these Japanese people, who took me
to some of the Japanese only bars.
And that was really fun 'cause
then they were all talking
to me and asking what
my favorite anime was,
knowing the Japanese titles
came in very handy that day.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Of course.
- Yes it's just a lot of fun, I mean it.
when it works and you go
out and you meet people
and they're actually cool and it's fun.
It's like the best thing ever.
- I feel like you got quite
a lucky experience though,
especially in Golden Gai, because-
- I think so.
- Yeah I've heard a lot of
horror stories about Golden Gai.
- You could easily go there
and just have not meet anyone cool,
and yet be bored, spend a lot of money.
- Because I've been to
quite a few smaller bars
and establishments that are outside,
like just outside the Golden Gai,
this is really fucking cool.
Gaming bar that Chris Brown took me to
literally across the road from Golden Gai.
- Wanapo.
- I think its called One Up, yeah, yeah.
- One Up I have been there.
- Yeah. And it's tiny,
there is just one bar,
it can only maybe seat six people,
but it's a proper gaming
bar, we're not talking about
the one thing you guys
look into in the UK.
It's a legit-like gaming bar
and that one was really fucking cool
and way cheaper than Golden Gai.
But the problem is that those kinds
of places don't come
up in Google searches.
It's almost always like,
when do you drink Shinjiku?
Golden Gai always comes up.
- I noticed there's a lot of bars in Japan
that are fucking tiny, and you go in there
and it's like I really liked the vibe,
'cause it's a really intimate vibe.
'Cause it can only fit
like five to six people.
And there's only one bar
and you sit at the counter
but I do like that vibe and I don't know
how they stay in business?
'Cause there are so many in Japan.
- And they are so hidden away.
- Yeah. There's so hidden-
- Like the cigar bar,
we went to in Ikebukuro,
I was like, how the fuck
would anyone be like, yes,
let me go into this tiny building,
go all the way up to the sixth floor.
And there it is right there.
It's like, how would you
know that that's right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like it could be just
someone's apartment for rental.
It probably is.
- It probably is
- That they just remodeled.
That's kind of the size
we're talking about,
like an apartment in Tokyo just-
- Yeah. Like a one room
apartment in Tokyo.
- Or you took me to that
bar that was like...
It was like an apartment,
someone's apartment,
in an apartment building
that have been converted
into a ping pong bar.
- Oh yeah.
- What?
- And I was like, what the fuck is this?
They served food and everything.
It was fucking weird.
- So that...
Sydney actually discovered that
because she read a manga
that I was based on,
a manga that had that
bar and she Googled it
and that bar actually existed.
So it's this ping pong bar that has
this massive ping pong
table in the middle.
- It's like going into
someone's living room
it's so weird.
- To get there, we had to go
down the dodgiest alleyway.
It was literally this handwritten sign
that says ping-pong bar,
go down this alleyway.
And so we go down this alleyway,
it's a dirty, dirty alleyway.
- Take some sheep from PT.
- Like there could be someone
doing heroin around the corner
you have no fucking clue.
So we go in there and then we
have to go up these stairs,
and it was just the stone stairs
that someone's probably
pissed on, you know.
That kind of bar.
As we go up and then it's
just someone's apartment.
It's just literally someone's apartment.
But then they opened the
door and it's a proper...
They've properly remodeled it into a bar.
And I'm thinking, man,
how would anyone fucking discover this?
'Cause this is just hidden away,
down too fucking dodgy alleys
that I would not go down.
- That's what I'm saying.
It's like there are so
many where I'm just like
you wouldn't, if you
didn't have a curious mind
and you weren't afraid
that you might possibly get
stabbed down this alleyway,
but there are so many
places where it's just like
you'd never be able to see.
- I mean, I try think Shinjuku is good
especially if you're a
foreigner 'cause you can...
I think a lot of people in Shinjuku,
are like wanting to meet foreigners
and stuff like that, or Shibuya,
so if you stayed with
those two places yeah
the super touristy and
everyone knows about them.
But I think a lot of
places outside of that
you probably won't find
people who are super
eager to talk to foreigners.
- Maybe Ikebukuro to an extent.
- Maybe Ikebukuro, yeah.
But that's as far as
you'll probably go, right?
- I mean, in Shinjuku,
you'll definitely find people
who wanna speak to you
if you're a foreigner.
- And it's like sometimes you go
to a bar and the people serving you
have time to speak to you as well.
- Yeah that's fun.
- Yeah. I like that experience.
Like the one place we went to
that started playing all
of our YouTube videos.
So there was this bar
that we went to, right?
There was this bar that we went to,
a really small intimate bar. And they...
I can't remember who
brought up the conversation,
but I remember they found out that Sydney
was a YouTuber, 'cause
Sydney was there as well.
She makes the stupid
mistake of telling her
her YouTube channel.
- Oh my God.
(Garnt laughing)
So this bar has four...
Has about three TVs in it, right?
And so, as soon as the bar
lady hears her YouTube channel,
she just Chromecasts Sydney's fucking...
(Joey laughing)
Sydney's videos
(Garnt laughing)
Sydney's videos all over the bar,
where other people that are
also drinking there on this bar.
So we're just there watching
Sydney's YouTube channel,
and she's just dying inside.
- That's a fucking nightmare, isn't it?
That's the one thing you shouldn't do
if you have a YouTuber friend,
is play their videos in front of them.
- Oh yeah, exactly.
- What is it about that?
I've never understood that.
- Just hearing your own voice.
So you being not like being silly, right?
It hurts.
- But it's just like you're...
It's like you're okay with you.
It's such a weird dilemma
'cause my cousin asked
me that same question,
which is like okay, so
you're all fine with me
watching your videos, as
long as you're not there.
But the moment you're there,
you don't want me watching the video?
Like how does that make sense?
I'm just like, I don't
know, I just don't like it.
I just don't like exactly the same.
- Like I hate it when I have to rewatch my
video to check it, like-
- I'm fine with that.
- Are you?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm just like-
- I used to not be.
And then now I'm like,
God, I love this video.
God I love it.
- God I love that guy.
- I love this part.
Damn you Conner.
Damn, that was a funny joke
Conner. I'm proud of you.
- Yeah. I don't mind
rewatching back on my video
that I'm editing for example,
if I'm the only one in the room,
but if someone's standing behind me,
like micromanaging me and
watching out the video
I'll be like please, leave.
I don't want you watching this right now.
You can go watch it after it's uploaded,
when I'm not there.
Yeah, I don't get it.
It's weird.
(Garnt laughing)
- Do you remember the
time that you accidentally
deleted the video while
we were out drinking?
- Oh my God.
- You what?
This is one of the worst to have...
Look at what happened to us,
we were at a friend's house,
and they were Chromecasting
all my fucking videos to the Chromecast.
And I don't wanna watch my videos.
- This is about 2:00 AM in the night,
so we're pretty drunk at this point.
- And I'm, so fucking bad.
So here's my most recent
video and had a sponsor on it.
And so, here's what happens, right?
When you have the YouTube app
and someone's Chromecasting
and you're also connected,
you can move the video, skip it, whatever,
and it was said like, Oh,
I could click on the
playlist of the cute videos,
and it said...
I clicked it, and my video was on
and I was like I'm gonna turn this off so,
I click it and there was no off button,
there was only delete
video and I was like, well,
delete video from the Chromecast.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
So I deleted the video on the spot,
bear in mind I haven't even
paid for the sponsor yet.
And it got paid like...
And I uploaded like two days ago,
and then I realized 10 minutes later,
I'm like, I'm looking at my channel
and I'm like, where's the video gone?
(Garnt laughing)
Wait, wait, did I delete the video?
And then I was just sitting
there for like all nights.
Sorrying up, thinking I
deleted the fucking video,
what am I gonna do?
Maybe they won't notice I deleted video.
And then on the taxi
backup, which was gone,
I was like, God, I think I fucked up.
And what do I do? I
deleted the sponsor video.
I don't know how do I play this off?
- Wait, is this recently?
- No no no, it was like two years ago.
- This is back in England.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah.
- It was just like yeah, ages ago.
- I remember Conner
calling and telling me,
it's like, yeah, I
think I deleted a video.
I'm like, Oh, I mean,
it's still like this.
It's not that bad we just re-upload it
and he's like, no, I mean,
it's a sponsored video.
I haven't been paid for a year,
and do you think the sponsors will notice?
I'm just like, okay.
(Joey laughing)
That's a pickle that you are in.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- A bit of a pickle.
- And then like they...
I can't remember who,
which sponsor it was.
I'm pretty sure they probably
shouldn't tell anyway.
'Cause they wanna have some fun.
They emailed me two days
after, they were like,
hey, what was the video
called? Where's it gone?
And luckily, I've just been dealing
with a ton of copyright issues.
And so I emailed them back and
being like, Oh gosh, darn it.
That YouTube copyright
is doing its magic again.
They've blocked the video worldwide.
That's why I'm like
retyping all the things.
I'm like I'm pretty sure I can fix it
by tomorrow at 8:00 AM.
So I uploaded that and they were like
great work on it back up.
I'm like, thank you, man.
I'm so glad I fixed it.
- Wow! You giga brain.
And I was like, Oh my God,
I fucking didn't see that.
So, yeah I was really drunk.
I wasn't even that drunk.
I wasn't even telling you.
I was just like lightly.
- So, wasn't that really dumb?
- Oh yeah. I was just really fucking dumb.
I just did it and I was like,
fuck, that's a bad thing.
(all laughing)
- Can you just please fire me?
Oh my God.
- I paid for it in the end though.
- That's good.
That's a YouTuber's
worst nightmare though.
- Deleting the video was not so bad,
but having to explain to someone-
- Why you deleted.
- Yeah. I think it's like, you know,
when you have to explain to your parents
that you've fucked up in some kind of way.
And you're like, man, I
really have to hype myself up
to just explain to mum and dad
why this thing has happened.
- Oh my God.
- That's terrible.
- But going back to Japan nightlife,
how do we keep going off
on these fucking tangents?
- It's fun, let the tangents happen Joey.
All the fun is serious.
- I'm okay with it, I'm okay.
I'm just impressed at ourselves
that we can tangent that fucking far away
from whatever it is we
we're talking about.
But one place I like to
go to a lot is Bagus.
- Oh yeah, I like Bagus too.
- Have you been to Bagus?
- I have not been to Bagus.
- Okay, okay.
'Cause I was saying
before that I was like...
I didn't remember if it was you
or Conner who hasn't been to Bagus.
- I have been to Bagus plenty of times.
- But yeah. So Bagus to explain
is it's like a darts, pool, ping pong.
- This is more of other stuff as well
it depends on some other places.
- It's a Manga cafe as well.
So basically where I did
the manga cafe video, that's a Bagus.
So they have a bunch of
different Bagus that sometimes
they focus on the manga
cafe side of things,
sometimes they focus on the pool
and darts bar side of things
but basically, it's
this 24/7 establishment
that's where you can just go
and get drinks and just hang out,
play pool and stuff like that.
- There's a ton in Shinjuku and Shibuya.
- Yeah, yeah a lot, a lot.
But I'm surprised that you haven't been.
I don't know, I don't think that...
Yeah I don't know, I just haven't been.
- It's a...
I think it's one of those places
'cause you wanna spend at
least two, three hours there
and you don't really wanted
to do it before your meal.
You don't really wanna
do it after your meal
'cause that's like best drinking hours.
So it's normally like, you
know, it gets to 1:00 AM
you're like, what do you guys wanna do?
I don't wanna keep drinking that much
'cause I'll just string your Bagus.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- It's fine I mean, it's
kind of pricey though.
- It is a little-
- If you're there for like three hours
that shit adds up fast,
'cause they charge you per-
- Half an hour.
- Yeah half an hour.
And then you're buying drinks on top.
Which of the drinks kinda little pricey.
- I mean, you can get
all you can drink though.
Of course.
- And you, I don't even know that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. You can
do all you can drink in Bagus.
But again, you have to be prepared to stay
for at least two hours, right?
- Yeah. 'Cause I know they do a package
that's like till the sun comes up package,
where it's like one to 6:00 AM,
and it's quite cheap, but
obviously you're committing-
- But it's like, I'm gonna stay up
till 6:00 AM to play pool.
- There's only so much pool you can play
before you're like this
just isn't fun anymore.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
We both aren't good at pool
and we've been doing it
for 30 minutes and I'm starting
to think I don't like this.
- I feel like I get better
when I'm drinking at pool.
- I don't know, that's the alcohol
making you think you're better.
(all laughing)
- It's not like you're getting better.
Your opponent would choose just as drunk
as he was getting worse.
- So I think I just doubt
myself too much where...
When I'm like playing pool sober,
I think when I'm about two pints in,
I just start hitting shots.
I'm like, for some reason it just goes in,
and then I have four drinks
and then I start getting worse again.
I don't, I feel like there's a sweet spot
where I'm slightly tipsy and
I'm a fucking goaler at pool.
- I'm like that with bowling.
- I like the darts, because
there's not a dart board.
It's like an arcade
machine with a dart board.
- It's like yes, I can electric-
- And some of them are so fucking overkill
and what they are, like
there was one more,
it's like you could play
on a whole RPG, in darts.
- Yeah, that's right. I remember that.
- And I was like, what the fuck is this?
And it was like,
your dart would do extra amount of damage.
(Garnt laughing)
I mean, it's so hard with a straight face,
like if you're on a date
or something being like,
hey, do you wanna play the RPG darts?
- That sounds amazing.
- It's pretty great for the first time.
But then some of the
levels were so bullshit
You had to get like-
- You needed to be like a fucking God.
- Yeah, you had to get triple twenties,
like every single one, I'm
like, this is bullshit,
Medusa should die way
easier than this, come on.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, but it's those
little touches, right?
That I think add to the whole Bagus-
- This is a lot more fun
that you don't have to count
in the darts 'cause the
machine just does it for you,
- Exactly, exactly.
- And it does make it a lot.
- 'Cause I've to a lot
of old-fashioned pubs
in Australia where there
is like a dart board-
- But you get the real
darts in all of those pubs?
They have these fucking
flimsy plastic darts.
- But it's also just as dangerous as well.
- But I love the danger.
- Ooooh I got a sharp
metal object!
- The drunk danger,
it's exciting, Joey.
- No, I'm good, man.
I'm too old for this shit.
- When you meet those people in the UK
that are like full pints in...
Are getting nailed, they get
like the peak performance
out of four pints. It's insane.
- I'm like I was bowling,
I fucking suck at bowling while I'm sober,
but I've quickly discovered the other day
that if I drink two or three pints,
before bowling, I can do
like a fucking Turkey,
like I don't know tomorrow.
- Of course you just
don't think, you just-
- I'm just like throw a ball, half pint.
- I don't know why, but I
think bowling is the most
depressing activity out
of all of the activities.
- Really?
- I think so.
- I feel like bowling with alcohol is fun.
- It's fine.
- But bowling without alcohol is boring.
- I think, I feel like I like bowling
because I didn't really
play it growing up.
Like I know it's...
You're either the kid
who fucking used to bowl
all the freaking time for fun,
or you were that one kid
who would only ever bowl-
- Fuck bowls are for fun?
- So a lot of people do,
in the UK apparently.
- Do they?
- Yeah. A lot of-
- Why do you think bowling is depressing?
- I don't know, there's an air to it.
(Garnt laughing)
- There always-
- It just doesn't
hit different.
- Okay. So I went...
Okay. This isn't an exclusive incident.
A lot of the places are like this,
but I'm just giving this for an example.
I went to a place in California.
Very nice area of California.
And somehow in California
this place that was very
like, seemed very normal.
There's just this one place.
And somehow this bowling
place was the only place
that gave me mega redneck vibes.
And I went in there
and it was very much just like that.
But what it seemed like
there was just a bunch
of people who, you know,
like were, I don't know.
- Have you been bowling in Japan though?
- No, I haven't.
- Well then maybe it might change, right?
- Unless there's screens
and shits fucking like,
Prrrrrrrrr! you got those
stuff like a tickle 10,
woooooo!
Like a guy comes over, congratulates you,
unless that happens no way, no way.
- I mean it, there is-
- How can bowling be any fucking different
with Japan, to other countries?
- I mean, there's no rednecks.
(all laughing)
'Cause I've like to me it
just sounds like the...
You said it was the era about it.
- But then this whole, okay.
Although I live there kind
of like bowling places
for some reason, universally, are the most
semi rundown places out of any
of the entertainment things.
I don't know why, bowling's always...
Like places always look the worst.
- I mean, I can see that.
- Does anyone understand what I mean?
- But the difference is
that bowling alleys in Japan
are run by round ones, so
they'll usually have the first...
We usually with like a
lot of big round ones
which is like a huge arcade
chain, if you don't know,
but it's like, the first three floors
are the arcades and the
rhythm games or whatnot.
And then the next four floors
are all the bowling exits.
- I mean, to me it's just like an activity
to do when you're drinking.
- I enjoy it, but it's...
I do think it's the worst
activity out of the bunch.
- Why? Why?
- There's plenty of time
to talk to your mates
and you just throw ball every few minutes,
- And you get a laugh at
your mate being shooted ball.
- 'Cause he know like everyone's
too invested in the bowling
and we're not talking, right?
Or nobody's invested in the bowling.
And the moment someone-
- Well, that's not the kind of people
you should be going bowling with.
- Tell me the perfect
level of bowling ratio
to conversation ratio
I should be expecting
because what happens is,
and this happens every single
time you go bowling, right?
Everyone's talking, Oh, it's my turn
but I was in the middle
of a fun conversation.
I don't really wanna bowl.
So do you just fucking
throw her like a med bowl?
But because you're already 10 points down,
you're not gonna win this one.
You're not gonna get a
strike, let's be realistic.
'Cause you're kind of shit at bowling.
And you know, then someone
or sometimes you...
Okay, so then, sorry, I'm losing my...
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- If I'm getting tilted over bowling.
- So then, you go up, you
miss out on the conversation
and just feels like you're speed dating,
but the one person is
not getting a date who
keeps going out.
- But I get that. If it's...
If you're only going bowling
with your date, right?
If there's only two people bowling-
- No dates, it's just mates.
It's like, you're in a group
and then you leave the conversation
and then no one's really giving a shit
about the bowling because
am having a conversation.
Or its vice versa.
- It's just like a background
activity you know what I mean.
- Then what's the point?
Don't do something else.
- This is exactly the same
as like darts and stuff.
- That's also what I had to say.
It's exactly the same
as like darts or pool.
- Now darts, you can keep talking
while you're playing
darts with each other.
- You can keep talking while you bowl.
- You gotta like, what are you gonna do,
follow him up to the bowl?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What are you gonna do? Follow
him up to the thing like,
okay, okay, keep going. Oh,
nice bowl, lets go back,
now lets go talk.
- Yeah, I do that sometimes.
- Fuck off.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I would be like, fuck off
Jerry I'm trying to bowl here.
- Whatever it is, that
doesn't make a lot of sense
'cause you are like I don't
give a shit about the bowling.
I only care about the conversation right?
- Because at bowling, I give
a shit about the bowling.
And then when I'm talking,
when it's someone else's turn,
I give a shit about talking.
- You're one the most
difficult fucking bowler
I've ever seen.
- I just feel like it's a dichotomy
and it shouldn't exist fully.
- There's so many activities
I can think of that you know.
- No, the easier pool.
While you're doing the pool, you can talk.
While you're doing darts, you can talk.
Everything else you can
do without like talking.
- Just like 'cause it's a group activity,
'cause your pool and darts I feel like
it's just like two people that's doing it.
- You can do it with group like pool.
You can all sit around
the table and enjoy-
- Yeah, but there's only
two people playing pool.
- Yeah, but okay, with bowling-
- You can do it like tag.
- Because it's such a distance,
one, too much for walking.
Can I just put that out
there, too much for walking?
- From such a distance?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You have to walk far enough away.
while can't be in the car.
Okay. This is going to
sound so fucking dumb.
All of this sounds dumb I realize,
but you have to walk far enough away
where you're then
leaving the conversation.
- But you don't have to
leave the conversation?
- No, you lost. You're gone Joey.
You're gone. You're out of it.
- If the conversation is...
Like how, you're not gonna
be like fucking far away
for five minutes, you're
up there for three seconds.
- That's enough to leave the conversation.
- I'll be honest, I've never thought
this deeply about bowling.
- I think this deeply
about everything in my life
except the music and story.
(all laughing)
- So in your mind, are you
thinking like this could be
optimized? This situation
could be optimized?
This isn't speed running fun.
You know, this is fun with extra steps.
- I don't think there's
too much gap between...
No one needs that much
run-up when they're bowling.
And if you do something's wrong with you.
Let's shorten the distance
between where the seats are
and where the alley starts.
- Well then...
But I mean, you don't gonna
have a 500 meter run up to bowl.
- I know some people who are
like, I need the full length.
- Well then I don't wanna go
bowling with people like that.
That just sounds like a dush.
(all laughing)
You taking this bowling
shit way too serious.
- I just think that bowling
is a not very optimized sport
for friendship engagement.
(Garnt laughing)
I'm gonna put that out there.
I just think it's not the best.
You know, what can I say
gentlemen? I mean it.
- I don't know, I felt like...
Okay, 'cause I've been bowling with like-
- I'm sure there is one people out there
that are like, Conner knows
what he's talking about.
He's not monkey brain.
- Yeah, well, then they
are the kind of people
I don't wanna go bowling with.
- Because I don't know.
There's always gonna be those comments
'cause they're gonna be
like, Oh, I'm not alone.
I need to speak up.
- Finally.
- Also bowling feels like an activity
where I shouldn't have to change my shoes.
You know what I mean?
It's that level of activity,
that isn't serious enough
to warrant me changing clothes.
- I will admit, the shoes part
is kind of bullshit, yeah.
- Like it's not like
you're going rock-climbing
or something.
Like I understand the need
to bring like, you know
flexible clothing, right?
It feels like an activity
that shouldn't require me
changing clothes.
And I hate the fact that
you always get the most
disgusting rancid shoes, that feels so
yeah, okay, sure, they spray it.
They give it a little alcohol spray
like that does fucking anything.
The shoe is disgusting.
- Okay, to be fair though,
Japan is really good, right?
With that cleanliness and stuff like that.
So I've never gotten...
I've had that in Australia where like-
- Still I don't wanna
fucking wear my fucking
Wales Waldo shoes while
I'm talking to my friends,
eating the most pathetic
fries in existence
that had been half cooked, while we have
a half good conversation
and overpriced alcohol.
I just think bowling
needs to be done better,
and it's depressing as
fuck, I don't know why.
- What's like with someone
with childhood trauma,
bowling alley.
- Who hurt you Conner?
Show me on the door where...
Show me on the doorway bowling is-
- Show me on the bowling ball.
- No no no.
- My closing statement on bowling.
- Okay. There's a question
I need to ask you.
Because have you had
bad bowling experiences
when you were a kid or is it something
that you developed as an adult?
- Yeah, as I become an adult
all this became a thing.
Because...
But, now that I have that
thought now where I was like,
you know what?
I just realized, 'cause bowling places
always had arcades, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Garnt] Yeah.
- I had more fun on the
arcade than the bowler
whenever I went bowling.
So what does that say about bowling?
'Cause you know, when there was like...
If you would have a party with 12 kids,
you are waiting a long fucking time
before your turn.
- I feel like you
don't enjoy bowling for the same reason
you skipped stories.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, I want the game play.
- Like if you could just
bowl 10 balls in a row,
and just like...
And then have conversation,
I'm sure you would enjoy it then.
but you're just like, skip,
skip, skip, skip, skip.
- I think, because it's like...
I don't know if you're like this but
when it's like not my turn
I have a tiny bit of
anxiety of like, fuck,
when's it gonna be my turn?
I don't know when it's gonna be my turn.
But I don't get called out?
I don't wanna be that much.
- You're not that serious.
- I know it isn't but this is the thing.
I have someone out there.
- You're only throwing
balls to an alley way.
- Someone out there
viewing experiences where
you're just like, yeah,
it's kind of anxious
just not knowing when I'm
gonna to fucking stand up
and throw something.
(all laughing)
Like I just don't like to know that okay,
I'm gonna just do it and
then I can come back.
- You treating it like it's
a fucking quick time event.
Like you can go out whenever you want.
- I just wanna talk to my
homies or play the arcades.
Can we separate them both?
- Well then maybe you'll enjoy bowling
if it was a one player game. You will just
play bowling by yourself.
They'll be like finally,
I get all the time.
- You know my best experience bowling was?
Wee Sports, that was the
best project. You know why?
No waiting, I just throw
that shit-
- And its 100% optimized.
- And you had that a 100 pin ball
that should be fun as fuck.
I love watching YouTube videos
of people getting like a 1000 pins.
It's just amazing. It feels good.
- Well then maybe we should do that.
Just we bowling.
- Yes, we bowling.
- No, no. I still gotta wait
for you to do it yourself,
I don't like that.
- You know you can skip it if you want.
(all laughing)
- Skip Joey's turn.
- Yeah. Skip, skip, skip.
- Yeah. I feel like talking
to you for enough times
I'm like, yeah, I kind of
get the monkey brain now,
it's starting to make sense.
I'm like scientifically dissecting
how you're breaking away.
- I just think, 'cause you know,
it's not my pool or darts so constantly
like talking and next to each other.
Doesn't really fucking
matter when it's my turn,
but bowling, 'cause it's like, hard,
I have to walk up and you know.
- But why don't you walk up with them?
- And also, you know,
okay, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm never been a big fan
of having to pick the ball.
I own for it. I'm kind
of sick of doing that.
Like, 'cause you've been there, right?
That one place where they don't
have your fucking hand size.
It's like they're too fucking
big where it feels like
you're tryna grab three
fucking food containers,
(Garnt laughing)
like large, or it's like,
yes, I want my fingers to be crushed
to death and potentially just pull my...
Like dislocate my finger
when I throw this.
And you know 'cause you've
been to a place like that.
- No I haven't.
- Fuck off.
- That's why I'm laughing, because-
- Come on.
I've been to your place and you're like
I kinda enjoy this bowling
because none of these
fucking balls fit my hand.
- Well, the one thing I
will say about bowling
is that no matter ball
you choose somehow it just
doesn't feel right.
- It never feels good.
- Like you pick a ball and
you're like, this feels right.
And then you throw it like,
Ooh, that didn't feel good.
Let me go for the smaller one.
And then you throw it
and you're like, nah,
that feels too light.
So you go for the big one again.
And it just, I don't know-
- You never get the right one
and it's never satisfying.
- You're in a constant
state of anxiety to be like-
- You guys must have gone
to some shit bowling alley.
- You know, they don't fucking
clean those bowling balls
on the inside either.
- Okay. That's all the more
reason I wanna take you guys
to a Japanese bowling ball,
because every single thing
that you guys have been
complaining about the bowling
experience, I feel is
completely get rid of.
- I feel like I'm in the middle for this.
I don't hate bowling as much as Conner,
but if I would like to make like a TLS,
bowling's like good sea tale.
- Yeah. It's definitely one of the worst.
- Okay, I'm not gonna say that bowling
is an extreme experience or anything.
Like if there is a BET for me as well.
- You can say its like
the fairy tale all right.
- Its like the fairy tale
of entertainment sports.
(Joey and Conner laughing)
Like it's just a mid man.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Bowling is mid.
- I remember I went on a
date when I first got here
and they wanted to get a Bagus.
So I was like, yeah, sure, sure, sure.
Three Bagus.
And then at the back
of my head, I was like,
yeah, I'll take it easy on you.
And then I just started fucking
destroying them in that.
And they are out there like,
oh man, I guess you got lucky.
We started playing darts,
I started just fucking
crushing them in that,
and I'm like, yeah, good, know your place.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
That actually he beat me in darts.
- I just like...
Does the word casual mean anything to you?
Like just playing casually?
- Now bowling is a casual player sport.
I don't like bowlers.
- It's 'cause you can't win in it Conner.
(all laughing)
- Maybe that's why 'cause
I fucking suck at bowling.
Maybe that's why I hate it.
- I always wanted to
ask you, like going back
to the monkey brain thing,
like your opinion on gameplay,
and we've had a few comments about this.
Why don't you like fighting games?
That is-
- That is pool for you.
- The game genre that
would like in theory,
appeal to you the most.
- Yes, there's no story.
- It's probably like the
one type of video game
that I've just never enjoyed playing.
- Why is that?
- I have no...
I think is like the difficulty
curve is insanely high,
and I feel that like, I
don't wanna sit there,
and have to research combos,
because sure, when I pull
one off, I'm like, cool,
that animation was fine I guess, you know.
I just don't feel like I care enough
about like to learn these combos.
Whereas in a game, like,
a first person shooter,
it's so intuitive that like-
- 'Cause it's just one button.
- Yeah, it's risky just
putting click, right?
And yeah, it is very...
Anyone can figure it out,
but it's that one simple
mechanic that you keep mastering
and you keep getting better and better.
And so it's the kind of like I've noticed
that I really only enjoy
games where it's easy
to learn how to master type of thing.
And fighting game is just hard to learn,
even harder to master.
- No, I still fighting games that are easy
to learn how to master.
- No. The Smash maybe?
- Yes. Smash, I think is the one.
- I really enjoy Smash. Smash is fun,
because I feel that
it's just, I don't know.
It's not like fucking Tekken rafter,
where I have to worry
about like the frames
and the frame spacing and stuff,
I don't wanna worry about that shit.
- I mean like people in
smash worry about that,
but you can get to a high enough level.
- But smash is a casual
game there I said it.
(all laughing)
No I'm kidding.
- That's what Socrates says.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That's a take.
- I just like fucking
made a thousand people
(inhaling quickly)
I'm kidding.
I love watching Smash competitive
but for me it's a party game, right?
- Oh yeah.
Well that's the great
thing about Smash, right?
Is that it's really fun
to watch as a party game
but it's also really fun process.
- The thing that's really hard
about fighting games is that
it's hardly ever a party game.
Right? Because whenever you are at a party
and people playing fighting games,
there's always that guy or two guys,
you know who you are, you
see people put on like,
Smash we'll take it, and you're like-
- 'Cause they never
leave that fucking couch.
They will never leave it.
If anything is pissed, they're not going.
They'll wait till they get home.
Fighting games don't wait.
- Like this is what they've
trained their entire life for.
They're like, okay, let me smash the move.
Let me smash all the people at this party.
And then they need to find
other people like them,
to continue on this path that
they've put themselves on.
- It's the same people who rock up
to an anime convention just
with that, like the game pad
and they're like, I know
why I'm spending this.
This is like speed.
There's no question
about where I'm spending
these three days.
Put me to the room with the Wee U's.
(all laughing)
- Because I feel like with
fighting games, it's yeah...
I enjoy watching fighting games more
than I enjoy playing them because
you get to a point where
you just smashing buttons
and you're like I kind of get it.
And then you go online or something,
and then you just get destroyed.
There is like the difficulty curve
as you said is just casual, but to be...
The difference between
a beginner and a casual
is so fucking massive.
- Oh it's huge.
- You know. Because you
go from button mashing
to having to learn like basic theory
of fighting games of basic combos,
and the difference between that-
- It's like counting frames and shit.
- Stuff like that
- The difference between the beginner
and the casual is so fucking hot.
- Okay. For example, in a
game of Overwatch, right?
A pro can be killed by someone
who is absolutely garbage at the game.
Like it's very plausible
that he could do that.
But in a fighting game,
fucking pro is never gonna lose
to a casual like that,
it's not gonna happen.
And I think that element
of like, all right, well,
if I just play better, most
of the time I'll always win.
Which is like...
- It's because of fighting games
there's no element of chance.
And anyway, like, especially if you're
at a pro level because they
just know what's coming.
- And I think its kind of fun
and that's the kind of stuff
that really drives me into like overdrive
of wanting to learn something.
Is that like, I had a chance
of beating that guy and
I could have done it
if I just keep practicing,
I'll easily get it.
Then I keep going, and
that's how I got into league.
- So then maybe if you just gave that a go
with like Street Fighter or Mortal Kombat-
- I reckon if you learn one
fighting game, you'll be-
- I reckon I will be hurt.
Which is why I don't want to,
'cause I'm already
trying to learn Japanese,
the last thing I need is
something else taking care
of my fucking life.
- Fair enough. Fair, fair.
- It's like fighting games.
People I know who like
fighting games, super chill,
but their life is fighting games.
They don't talk about anything else.
They're like, Oh, you had a nice day?
Oh, that's cool.
I had a nice day learning
this mash combos.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's like what? Like they'll bring it
up when it's not even in the conversation.
Yeah. I love Leonardo DiCaprio.
(speaking foreign language)
- That's what it sounds like,
sometimes it's just horrible.
- It was like Leonardo DiCaprio
which somehow turned into Smash.
It's like what? What the fuck?
That's my shame the way
I'd smashed my combos
and stupid stuff and it's like, what?
Just like stop.
- I will say like from the outside
looking in the fighting
game community looks
like one of the funnest
communities to be in.
- I love the trash talking.
- The trash talking is so good.
- Well, like in League of Legends.
They ban that shit and I'm
like, dude, I love trash.
I love trash talking in video games.
I think it's so fun.
(Garnt laughing)
- Maybe it's because of the trash talking
in some of those communities
just go a little bit too far.
- Maybe. I mean, Legal
Legends is not trash talk.
It's like, I'm good to
kill you and your family.
- It's like a legit threat sometimes.
- I reserve the right to just
type to someone you're bad.
Like I think that's...
Come off.
(Garnt laughing)
Someone can do it to me. I won't mind it.
It won't ruin my day. I'm not like-
- In a sense, that's one of the worst ways
to trash-talk right.
If you just stop and just typed in
you are bad in chat, lowercase, it's like,
(Joey quivering)
How dare you.
It's like the worst type of insult.
- So I competed on the...
One time they did a gaming tournament
for my universities,
and I was really fucking
good at Cod. And so I-
- You were one of those kids, aren't you?
- Yeah I competed on that. So-
- Of course you were called the wicked,
of course you were.
- So there was this thing...
Oh, my mates will just go
on this whole tangent then,
now if you guys are fine
with that, I used to...
When I was 15, I went to a
fuck ton of Cod tournament's,
because Modern Warfare 3,
and if you've ever played,
you would play Modern Warfare?
- A little bit.
- I stopped at Modern Warfare 2.
- Okay. So Modern Warfare
3 had this thing where
you could pay like $40 a year or whatever
for the pass for all the maps.
And then you can also go on
this website that they had,
and they're like tournaments,
and I entered one
and they would have a prize for, okay,
first 10 people get a shot
glasses of Call of Duty,
(Garnt laughing)
which is like ladies fucked anyone who's
over the age of 18, but 15 on me was like
( Conner straightening up)
wow!
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I can pull my G fuel into that.
- Wow, wow! I can be
like can I get something
for playing called.
So I went to my mate's house 'cause I know
that my parents would never let me
pull an all-nighter because bear in mind
these tournaments were...
Essentially what they
were was a stat tracking,
so it would be 24 hours tournament,
of where you would just...
It would be like most
kills in team death match.
So you would just go into a normal team
death match and just play.
And then it would count
how many kills you hadn't
team death match before
and how many death sets.
- So basically just like who can get
the highest score.
- Yeah, right. So, basically it was like,
you just fucking keep
playing and I shit you not,
I played fucking like capture the flag
for 20 hours straight during this to-
- Win these shots like hell.
- To win these shot glasses.
And I was like crippled after it was like,
it was worth it.
(Joey laughing)
I came like...
I won so many at that
time that I was able to go
to sleep confidently knowing
that no one would be up
we'd be able to like overtake me.
I think it came like third
or something, so I won.
And then, what happened
was that it all changed.
They changed it so that
it was three hours now,
way more manageable.
(Joey and Garnt nodding)
I was like, sweet, I
can enter all of them.
And they were like most flags defended
and captured, that weird shit.
So sometimes I would be sitting
at my base, just waiting
for someone to take my
flag, kill them, get it back
and then just go back and camp.
And I would do this shit.
I won like 15 tournament or
something in the end. I won-
- So my room was full of shackles.
- I'll tell you what though.
- What was the best prize you got?
- iPad Pro, at the time-
- [Joey] Oh wow.
- [Garnt] Wow.
- iPad, when I was like 17,
the brand new iPad at the time
my mum thought that I was a drug dealer.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Because she was like, what the fuck?
'Cause all this stuff turned up.
I won this huge poker
set, wooden poker set.
They only made 250 of them
and I still have it at my, at my house.
'Cause I couldn't sell it,
'cause it was worth about 700 pounds.
- Jesus, fuck.
- It's a wood box this
big and you open it up
and all these wooden
poker chips, handcrafted,
cord tapes, dealerships,
metal, immaculate.
I'll show you pictures.
They'll be on screen
right now. It's crazy.
And I was doing these for ages.
I won like three skateboard decks.
I don't skateboard.
What the fuck should I do with it?
A hoodie, two coaster sets
that I still use actually,
metal coasters with like Cod skulls on it.
Who the fucking cream stuff?
One like wall decals,
which I couldn't use.
I sold most of the
stuff on eBay, but yeah.
I won an iPad Pro, which is one time.
And then, I got banned, from competing.
- Why?
- 'Cause you were too good?
- No, no, no. I...
So, the rules were not well-defined.
And I was...
I don't know how to, how do I describe it?
- You sneaky mother fucker?
- You bent the rules to say-
- Listen, if I saw an opportunity
to win an iPad Pro
I'm gonna take the
opportunity to win an iPad Pro
'cause it seemed all legit.
So about halfway through these tournaments
I realized, okay, I'm trying
really hard to win these
but I think I can also do it a lot easier.
So basically what I would do is
I'd won a bunch of these tournaments,
and I used that notoriety
from those tournaments,
to recruit people to come,
'cause all it would do
is track your stats.
So everyone else on
your team didn't matter.
So if you had a team that was
coordinated into making sure
that you were the one
getting everything, right?
- So you basically smuffed.
- So what I did was is I got
these five Swedish players.
For some reason the Swedish and Norwegian
do it always fucking amazing in Cod.
They were way too good.
And I promised them if they help me win
all these tournaments,
I would join their clan.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I was like negotiating online.
I would be like I won't
shout you out, I will join.
Bear in mind, I wasn't worth anything.
But to them, they were like, yo,
he's winning all these tournaments.
We've got to get this guy in.
So did you know of the game mode
like kill confirmed?
- No.
basically a game of
where you killed someone
and they would drop a tag
and you'd have to collect it.
So there was one tournament that was like
whoever gets the most kill
confirms in three hours, won.
So what I did was I told these guys,
I was like, hey, kill these
dudes, and put a marker
on the map of where you dropped
it and don't collect it.
And I just ran around,
collecting them all.
I didn't kill anyone.
And it was...
And I should have not done that
because what I knew was happening was like
first place was like
1200, second place 400,
(all laughing)
And it raised like a lot of alarm bells.
The people were like,
that doesn't seem fair.
So I got away with it for
two or three tournaments
before people started really complaining.
And people were like, this isn't fair.
He's winning everything 'cause of this.
But then the thing was,
people started doing it.
So then it was a matter of everyone
was fucking cheating each other.
(all laughing)
And because there was some
real fucking big boy prizes.
There was a Jeep, one of
them, which I fucking,
I was like 10 points off
winning a fucking Jeep
at the age of 16, bear
in mind, I was killed.
I was winning all these
prizes under my dad's name.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they wouldn't
ship it to you if you were-
- Underage.
- underage yeah.
- They also made me fill out tax forms
which I couldn't even
legally fill out, which I-
- What did you tell your dad
that you were like filling out?
- I was like, dad, I
have won a bunch of stuff
and it's gonna turn up to
the house in a UPS fab,
about 20 items.
I need you to pretend
that you won them dad,
(all laughing)
And they were very visibly, like what?
And then they were like, okay, I guess.
And so the thing that got me banned
from these tournament's.
There was this one
price that was, you know
the movie battleship
with featuring Rihanna?
- Yeah.
- Yeah Rihanna.
I know that horrible movie.
- They were promoting
the movie Battleship.
One of the prizes was
you could rent out a whole movie theater
and take all your friends
to get drinks, snacks-
- Secure the whole battleship.
- I only thought to myself
the amount of street
credit I'll get for this.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
This is just an outstanding move I'll need
all the experience out
there and I was like,
Okay. Okay.
Okay. Bear in mind.
I have to say people
might've scored bullshit
on this whole thing,
but I was literally eight
hours a day addicted to Cod.
So straight up, like
made for me to do this.
So what I had was this was a
team death match tournament.
I remember this so vividly,
and team death mantra to kill them.
So what I would do is
I would ask my friends
to go around with riot
shields and Kaji replay,
don't kill anyone.
If you can trap them in a
corner, tell me where they are.
I'll come over and pop them in the head.
So what we would do is I coordinated-
- The mafia.
- It was literally.
- So you...
What incentive did you give them
to follow everything you said?
- Fucking nothing.
(all laughing)
I was keeping this all for myself.
I never ever told them once
I was gonna help them do it.
I was just like I'm just
gonna take the prizes
and you guys can help
me and they were like
it sounds good.
- That sounds like a good deal.
- It actually is great.
I do remember thinking...
So the Swedish dudes,
they had reason, right?
I said I would join that team.
I did join that team and
we won a lot of tournaments
but yeah, there are a lot of
the other people who helped me
out. No incentive whatsoever.
I just wanted to have fun.
It was entertaining as a fact
to just go in and do this.
And I won some of these
tournaments on my own
but I was sweating my ass off.
Like I would have to really play my best.
And so I thought, why
do that when I can just
get it secured?
I mean, it's in the rules,
the rules against it.
I was like, why am I sweating
when I can just guarantee the W?
Like, so yeah, I did that.
And by that time that
they implemented a feature
where you could see a heat
map of what was happening.
People were starting to see
that it was like 75 kills
to me, zero, zero, zero,
zero with my teammates.
And people were like,
hmmmm, hmmmm,
- That's a little sauce.
- It doesn't seem like a normal
game of team death match.
(all laughing)
He got a nuke.
(Conner flexing his shoulder muscles)
And so what happened was is that
they wanted to make an example out of me.
And they were like, no more doing this.
No one else is allowed to do this.
We've banned this from happening.
And so they banned me from doing it.
And I remember I spoke to the other...
'Cause there was like four of us
who won all of these tournaments.
And the other two were 30
year old men who worked
in construction companies and this is
all they would do in their free time.
And I felt bad for them.
'Cause that was like a 15
year old kid being like
I'm gonna take the money
that you probably need.
I don't need this shit, I'm gonna take it.
- Well I thought they banned you
and then you kind of became that.
You were like V for Vendetta.
(all laughing)
It was like I wanted to make a statement
and I got banned for it, but
it was worth it to get the W.
- Up to this day, I was like...
The one year after that
I was so fucking bitter
because I was like wasn't
in their fucking rules.
They just didn't make
an example out of me,
their website shut down five months after-
- Down with the government.
- Yeah. The website fails five months
after I was like, yeah, fuck you.
- Wow.
- They emailed me like two
years later being like,
Hey could you fill out
those tax forms we sent you?
I'm like, I just never did.
I'm like, what are you gonna do?
I live in a different country.
What are you gonna do, sue me?
- They can't sue you for that.
- I was 15 at that time.
- How legit was this website?
- It was the official Call
of Duty website. It was...
- Oh okay.
- If you wanted to go and track your stats
you'd have to go and do this.
And you would just get
10 pounds extra a year
to get access to the tournament.
- And you're that guy who just tries
to cheat every system in life.
- Oh dude, yeah. Like...
- Over-optimize everything yeah, yeah.
- It's like, if there's like loopholes
or corners to be cut, I'll
just always find them.
'Cause it's like, that's-
- You work smarter, right?
- Like why would I, work harder
when I can just do things easy?
I mean, that's what I want to do.
- That's what like every criminal says
(all laughing)
- So it was...
I was not cheating, there was no rule
against what I was doing
and they fucking...
They banned me 'cause I was
too good at their own game.
(Joey laughing)
- I wasn't cheating, I was
just bending the rules.
- Yeah I was outsmarting-
- I was so sad.
- I was outsmarting the system.
- I'm so fucking sad 'cause like...
- You are now, I was
outsmarting the system.
(all laughing)
- The only thing...
The only truth. Okay. Too bad that iPad.
I got mad mileage out of that iPad.
That was worth the goal.
That iPad was worth-
- I can Imagine.
- Like $2,000 at the
time, so that was amazing.
And my mum was like, still
even after it was like,
Hmmmm, if you got an iPad,
you start to send dick pics
to somebody's Conner?
Is that how you got the iPad?
- You selling drugs on the side?
- Are you winning son? Are you winning?
- There was such a fun time.
That was great, that was so fun.
I love doing that 'cause
I just won so much.
I wish I won the good
stuff like the Jeeps.
- That dude, that would
have been a bad flex
if you wanna chill with
a Jeep at 16?
- I was just busy
watching animated.
- Yes I am, I was yeah.
- I remember the Jeep I
wasn't close to winning,
but there was one time
where they had quad bikes.
Like four quad bikes,
worth about 10 grand maybe.
I came fucking fourth and it was
for the top three and I came four by draw.
- Oh wow.
- So I'd drawn for it and I
didn't get it because of that.
I was so annoyed.
I was like, mum, I didn't
get the quad bikes.
(Joey laughing)
I can't believe it.
(all laughing)
- Would you even be able
to use the quad bikes?
I suppose in Wales.
- In wales yeah you have plenty of people
to sell them too.
I think like four out of
the 30 people in my class
had quad bikes.
Like it's everyone had
quad bikes for some reason.
- Those were the guys who
like came in the top three.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Man, see my quad.
- That's how they got it.
- Yeah, that's how they got it.
(all laughing)
- It was yeah, man.
I think it would have been problematic
if I got that though because
I'm not sure how much
my dad could have bull-shitted,
'cause I imagine that
would have been a lot
more forms involved when
it came to a court plan.
Like UPS isn't just dropping
off a quad bike like-
- Holding his insurance
and everything right?
Yeah Yeah.
- Did he ever find out
how you got those stuff?
- Yeah. They knew. They were just
like the first few
tournaments that I said I won
they didn't believe me, until...
'Cause all of the stuff to end
up at once, like these 20...
I think I won around
15 tournament's total.
And they all turned up at
the same day, the prizes.
And my mum was like in complete disbelief.
She was like, you weren't lying?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What is this?
- Wow.
- I wish I could get my mum onto a test.
She probably has a better
memory of it than me
'cause I don't remember it very well.
- You are the epitome
of "I am winning dad".
- I literally was that
hyper competitive kid.
When I found something I
really liked, it was like,
I would get just insanely good at it.
- How I wish I could have
that, 'cause I like...
If I found something that I was...
'Cause in that sense you're
very much like a perfectionist
with that kind of things.
I'm not like that, I'm just like,
if I'm good enough, then
that's good enough for me.
- I can never be like that. We stopped.
But the problem is if
I don't have that drive
I kind of don't care about anything.
- Yeah, because like for me-
- It's so flirting .
- For me when it comes gaming, I...
In every kind of competitive game,
I always have this honeymoon period where
you're just learning the
game and it's just fun.
And then when you start playing ranks,
like ranked for the first few months,
I'm like yeah, this is pretty fun.
And then you get to
that you hit the ball...
You hit the wall, and that's for me
when it stops getting fun.
That stuff for me is
when it starts becoming
like a nine to five grind,
you know what I mean?
This is like, I'm not even
having fun grinding anymore.
This feels like another job.
I'm getting angry for some
reason over a fucking video game.
(Joey laughing)
- Flashback. When I was in
my promos, I was close...
I was one game away from
being in master Tia at TFT.
And I'd only been playing it for a month,
and I was like, I'm gonna
be a fucking pro at TFT.
- Yeah.
- I'm actually gonna be a pro.
And then I got demoted and I just lost
all interest in the game.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I was like to get better,
the amount of mind power
I'd have to like exert,
which will be too much.
I'm like, I can't do this.
You realize to get 10%
better, would take like
eight hours a day of playing.
It's like, I can't do it.
- It's not worth it.
- I can't do it.
- I'd rather be just like an average Joe
at like a lot of different things rather
than excel at like a couple of things.
- I think I'm the opposite.
I think that's what I've been.
I've been like really bad at
a lot of things in my life.
But the things that I
do, like you're like-
- Like you are really, really good at.
- 'Cause you are just super into it.
Normally when I'm into something
I rarely think about anything else.
It's like, I only wanna do this one thing
and I'm going to do it as much
as possible until I'm bored of it.
And then when I'm bored of it
I pretty much never come back to it.
It's weird.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's just the every episode, just like
the monkey brain
- I totally-
- Just gets like, yeah.
- I know people look at it...
I know people, I already see some curse,
you're like Conner must be bullshitting.
One or two of the stories
I've like messed up the details and had to
like fucking elaborate,
like go a bit extra but,
- I guarantee that the stories
where I'm talking about chess and-
- I get, I see so many
people in the summer,
it'd be like Conner's
- He's bullshitting.
- Kind of
experienced too much.
- Yeah, they're like he's bullshitting.
- No one human can experience
this much in his life.
- No, it's, it's normally the
the stupidest stories where I, you know,
maybe enjoy the details a bit more
to make it more entertaining.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- But the stories that I'm talking about
like that kind of stuff.
Yeah. That was that legit happened.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
I mean.
- 'Cause like I don't
remember a lot of my life
back at the time.
Back like I think, there's just...
I don't know if it's like,
obviously not with you,
but with Juju, do you have
a blank period in your life
where you just don't remember much
of things that happened?
- Of high school.
But that's just because I was doing drugs.
(Conner and Garnt laughing)
If I'm to be frank with
you, that's exactly why.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Are you keeping that
in? You want that in?
- I'm okay with that, I don't care.
(all laughing)
It is the truth, I don't remember it.
- Because there was the time
when we were talking about
how you were getting into anime
and then I think you mentioned that...
But there's a reason Cory said what?
I just stopped watching anime or like,
was he jacking off? Is that
what he was insinuating?
- Was he like selling his body for sex?
Like what was it? It's
like, no, I was doing drugs.
I'm just to put it out there.
Not hard Drugs.
I just like to pinpoint that,
not hard drugs, but yeah.
That's the thing, right?
Like that's where I had
that blank of just like
I wasn't really doing
anything with my life.
And all I was really
doing was playing music
or playing games but not to the extent
that you are playing games,
I was just like on new grounds
playing the bullshittest,
dumbest fucking flash games
that have ever existed.
- Yeah I guess for me, the only thing
I've been super invested
in is my career now,
which is YouTube, and I do
think of YouTube as a game.
- Yeah, it's totally a game.
- It's totally a game of ad.
- It's pretty wide being able
to like, you know, I guess-
- Optimize it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I guess 'cause I don't know,
the way I see it is kind of like-
- You have fucking optimized
YouTube game though.
- I don't know.
- I feel.
- I think that there are many aspects
that it shares with a game, right?
Unfortunately.
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
- I mean there's still a
huge creative aspect of it
but I think there's ways to like iterate
on yourself that are very game-like.
- I feel like social media
in general is a game.
You look at something like
Twitter, where I think...
I remember I've watched this series
by this guy called Charlie Brooker,
he made a series called the
Top Most Influential
Video Games of All Time.
And he put number one was Twitter,
and at first I was like
what the fuck is he talking about?
Twitter isn't the game.
And then you think about it where like,
Oh yeah, you play an avatar
in line to affirm numbers,
and the more he gets into it
the more numbers you affirm,
and I'm just like, you know,
he's kind gotta a point,
'cause like-
- Damn, he's right.
- Yeah. Nobody really...
You're like playing a version of yourself
but it's not like you don't
show all of yourself online.
No one ever does show themselves online.
- You've got to optimize
every tweet you make.
Should I rephrase it in this way?
Is this funny thing to Tweet or?
- I don't know how some
people can fucking tweet
like 50 tweets in a day.
I don't think I have 50 tweets,
like 50 thoughts in a
day, let alone like 15.
- Remember when...
Do you ever get those moments?
You're like, Oh, I wanna
find that one funny tweet
from that account.
And then you're scrolling
and scrolling and scrolling.
You're like, Oh, it's
only been seven hours ago.
What the fuck? Stop tweeting.
You tweet too much.
- It's like how many? That's
the thing it's like...
Are you just that kind of person where
you just can't think about
the thought to yourself?
It's like I have to put
this out into the world.
- We'll, shall people
get like a fucking coffee
at Starbucks like
(Conner mimicking with his fingers)
I got us coffee from Starbucks, oh my God!
- Stay relatable.
(all laughing)
My God. Yeah, Twitter is a game
and it's a hard game, but I enjoy it.
- Damn, that's gonna be, fuck....
I wanted to go an episode or two
I didn't tell a fucking
elaborate stupid long story
but I could pretty remember that I used
to fucking play Cod competitors.
(Joey laughing)
I didn't even get to the
reason why I brought it up
but that's a story for another time.
- Yeah, that's all right.
Well, we'll leave it
for the next episode.
Remember how this episode
was a power Japanese night?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Hey man, we spoke about
that long enough, Cod came up.
- I think it was like I said
everything I wanted to say
about Japanese nightlife.
- We'll come back to when
we've experienced more of it.
- I feel like there's so much
more of Japanese nightlife
We need..
- We'll see that Trash Tastes
special in a soap blend.
We're gonna go.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
If you don't know what a
soap blend is, it's a...
- It's a place where
you get clean with soap.
- You have a service-
- You cleanse yourself-
- You have a service
and they don't advertise
which soap they use.
They advertise which women are doing it.
And you can fucking figure out
why that's the case on your own.
- I would...
I was concerned with, well, what kind of
scrubbing method do they use?
- Yeah I was like, I
need to know the phrase,
is it grass-spread?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Do I bring my own loofa or
are they going to have one?
- Do I need to bring a shower cap?
- Do they use their own soap?
Or I bring my, like my organics.
- I have a whole gap
organic that I need to use.
Meanwhile, the guy's
getting the hand job next
to me and I'm like, well,
that's kind of wooo.
- I'm not okay with the soap.
- I've never been to one by the way.
Just wanna make that very clear
before someone fucking assumes so,
and I'm sure you guys have in as well?
- No, no, no,
- Joey? Joey? Joey?
we definitely haven't.
(all laughing)
- He's implanting that
thought, so its like, has he?
- No, no. Please no.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, but that's about
it for this episode.
- That's a pretty good way to wrap it up.
- But hey, check out these
amazing people on patron who support us.
Look at all these lovely people.
- These Pro gamers are good
at Cod and hate bowling.
Fuck bowling.
Hashtag fuck bowling.
- No don't hashtag bowling.
- Bowling is depressing.
- No it's normal
- Bowling is okay.
- Please comment your thoughts
on bowling down below.
- You know, what's not depressing though,
our Twitter and sub Reddit.
Yeah. Some great memes over there.
So follow us over on there as well.
And if you'd like to support the show
then make sure to go
over to a patron as well.
- Yeah. And I think
you've said everything.
I have nothing else to add to that.
- I looked over and you
are like, anything else?
- I saw you in like the corner
of my eye, and I'm just like
I don't know what you
expect me to say Joey,
you've literally shouted everything else.
- I'm just like I said
everything I had to say.
Help, please help. Please
in this misery right now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You can just say like, Oh
thank you very much goodbye.
And I'm like, what'd
you want me to say Joey?
- Say it, say it.
- Sometimes I feel like,
I'm not the monkey.
(Garnt laughing)
- What do you mean?
- If that's been trashed taste?
I'm not answering that
question, Joey. Goodbye
- Bye.
(upbeat music).